Hello Freak bitches.
That's right.
Where back.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by stamps.com it's
tough deciding where to focus your resources,
resources.
Is it really not for me?
For me,
it's very easy allies this lesson.
Sure.
I know how to focus my resources.
Do you think that men do is gross to Eliza?
Boys are gross.
I just like my dog.
No dog.
No,
you're not that girl.
Dogs in your lap.
I'm just being silly.
Anyway.
It's tough deciding where to focus.
Focus,
full case.
I can't get through this.
It's tough deciding where to focus your resources to grow your business,
but one thing I can tell you,
you do not need to waste valuable time going to the post office for mailing and
shipping.
Just use stamps.com to access all the services of the U s post office right from
your desk,
24 seven a.
You can do it naked.
You can do it drunk.
You could do it.
If you've got a wholesome crystal Meth,
you could use it and you can.
If you,
you know,
you might want to go over your packages and make sure you've got your point is
you can do it without all of the annoying things that most people have to deal
with when they're sending out packages.
If you have a small business,
you can print us postage from your office right from a regular computer,
regular printer,
very easy to do.
You can do it from your home.
You could do it from your desk at work.
You can do it anywhere that has a computer and a printer.
It's so easy.
Get posted for any letter or package,
any class of mail,
all for just a fraction of the cost of an expensive postage meter with
stamps.com you never have to go to the post office again.
You could spend your time where it matters most focused on your business.
We use stamps.com Brian Red Band sends out all those desk squad,
kitty cat tee shirts with stamps.com Thompson Guerra and Christina Palicki.
Christina,
what do I have a lisp?
The fuck is wrong with me today.
It's been in the presence of a beautiful and hilarious Eliza slessinger that has
me all tongue tied.
You Gross.
Again,
men are gross and then I agree,
I'm with you.
I'm on your side.
Uh,
and if you go now to stamps.com and you use the Promo Code j r e you can get a
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
which includes a free digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
So do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinjrethatstamps.com and enter
j r e it's quick,
it's easy,
it's convenient.
I have many friends that have experienced with stamps.com all of them have
positive stories.
They enjoy it,
they use it and you will too.
You freaks.
So go there,
go there and enjoy.
Enjoy the shit out of it.
We're also brought to you by Squarespace.
If you are thinking about starting your own webpage,
you're like,
man,
I need to make a web page.
But who,
where do I go?
Who do I get to design it?
I just,
I don't know anybody.
That's good.
I don't want to get ripped off.
Stop right there.
Squarespace is a method.
It's a website where you can create your own website yourself.
You can,
I could do it and I am a dummy.
Anyone can do it.
It's not hard to do.
If you can do simple tasks on a computer,
drag and drop point and click.
If you can add a picture to an email,
you too can use Squarespace.
It is an excellent platform for developing websites.
They have beautiful designs for you to start with.
All the style options you need to create a unique website for you or your
business.
It's a simple drag and drop interface and they offer 24 seven support.
You could also create your own online store very easily,
very quickly.
You can also sell digital music.
If you're a musician,
you can sell digital music.
If you're a guy who just likes to talk and you want to see if maybe people will
buy you talking,
hey,
fucking give it a shot.
Pow.
[inaudible] never know.
The point is Squarespace has got you covered.
Plans start at $8 a month and includes a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year,
responsive design,
your site will look awesome on any device,
which is really key.
If you do it yourself,
most likely it won't look the same on windows as it does on a Mac,
but with Squarespace they got you covered.
Whether it's android phones,
whether it's a tablet,
an IPAD,
it will look groovy on everything.
Squarespace also has a logo creator where you can create your own clean,
simple logo within minutes for a free trial and 10% off of your first purchase
goes to squarespace.com and enter in the code Joe.
That's squarespace.com enter in the code.
Joe,
I can't say enough good things about Squarespace and I like when I meet the
people behind the company and their coolest fuck and I met all the Squarespace
folks.
Not all of them.
There's some squares Briggs folks out there like what the fuck man,
you didn't meet me.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean all of them though.
I met a group that were from Squarespace and they couldn't have been cooler,
so I love that.
I love that I'm working with Nice people,
so squarespace.com enter in the code word Joe for a free trial and 10% off your
first purchase.
Another thing that I really like about Squarespace is that you can use
Squarespace.
You could try it out before you enter in your credit card information.
They let you try it.
They let you see what it's like and then if you like it,
if you say,
Ooh,
I this,
this website,
we don't be shit.
Then you enter in your credit card information.
They are that confident about the product that they're providing.
That's squarespace.com and use the code word show.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t on it is a
human optimization website.
We seek to inspire and give you the tools to get your shit together physically,
whether it's with strength and conditioning equipment,
whether it's with healthy foods and snacks like hemp force protein bars,
which are delicious and guilt free protein bars.
They're fantastic for you,
very high in protein and very easy to digest and they will not give you gas
unless you're one of those fucking Weirdos that just gets gas from everything.
And if that's the case,
hey fucker,
it's not our fault,
but if you're not that guy or gal,
hem forest protein bars are the shit you'll love him.
I also love the hemp force protein powder.
A,
we buy the finest protein powder from Canada,
the highest in protein and the finest meaning like,
I don't mean just fine,
like it's the most awesome,
but it's actually a finer blend of,
of protein.
So it's much easier to digest.
Um,
it's,
it's more expensive to do it that way,
but what we're trying to do it on it is just provide the very best things that
we can find,
whether it's the very best organic coconut oil,
the very best Himalayan salt,
like whatever we can find.
We try to find the highest quality stuff and sell you that.
Another new thing that we have is warrior bars.
What warrior bars are these new organic buffalo bars with buffalo meat and no
added hormones.
No antibiotics,
completely nitrate free and really delicious.
It's made the original native American recipe with um,
they,
they cure them with or secure them,
preserve them with cranberries.
Actually.
Um,
each bar is 140 calories,
four grams of fat and 14 grams of protein.
Super healthy for you,
no MSG,
no soy,
no lactose,
gluten free,
no antibiotics or added hormones,
a real true guilt free snack.
Uh,
go to [inaudible] dot com and check out all the different things that we have,
whether it's kettlebells,
battle ropes,
steel,
maces,
we just give you all the tools that you need to get your shit together,
to get your body in shape,
to get your mind firing,
to get your immune system kick in,
to get your endurance up to par bitches.
And we are committed to provide you with what I said,
inspiration and the tools to get your shit together.
Go to [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n,
N,
I,
t.
And if you use the Codeword Rogan,
you will save 10% off the supplements.
That's O,
n,
N,
I t.
And the code word is Rogan.
Eliza slessinger is here.
Why fuck around young Jamie.
Cue The music lab
experience.
I have friends that I see every now and again like,
dude,
we gotta fucking podcast again,
but no,
no more where we've fucking miss the mark and just lost the thread and send a
few emails back and forth and then dropped it and picked it up again.
Then you Elijah slessinger but we made it.
We made it happen.
You're here.
Uh,
what do you want to look at yourself?
You don't have to look at yourself.
You can shut them off.
Can to shut them off because it will still be on.
Are you freaking out?
No,
I'm fine.
You okay with the way you look?
You have been on TV.
Didn't you win a last comic standing?
Yeah,
let's open with that.
It's just everyone knows who they're fucking with.
Yeah.
People notch out.
Damn Bitch.
Who took,
who was on your season?
No.
One of note.
That is the truth.
Last comic standing just told her,
I'm like the ultimate fighter in a way where like you get to a certain point in
time where you're going to run out of talent,
right.
If you just keep going like you can't come up with 20 great new comedians every
year.
They didn't owe.
They can believe it.
I was coming back.
Hopefully they'll focus more on standup.
Who saw the host of your,
was it Jay Moore?
The host Bill Bellamy.
Oh,
Bill Bellamy.
Sweetheart,
sweetheart.
I never met that dude.
Um,
cannot say my last name but he's a sweetheart.
Slessinger is tough for black people.
Is tough for white people.
Is this lesson Gersh last thinker.
Schlesinger.
So I've been saying it wrong every time I met you.
You don't want to,
I just saw some girl.
It's almost as annoying as having a hyphenated last name.
Yeah,
that's gross.
Samuelson Jacobson.
Thank you.
It's like nobody cares.
Those people were pathetic.
Those dudes who changed their name for the girl and then they make their name a
hyphenated name.
You stop.
It's usually like a really horrible like English professor or like women's
literature,
like teacher from the northeast.
It's like I have to keep my,
maintain my last name is just like come on Alpha woman.
But he won two out but he has to pay for it.
Well that's Super Alpha Alpha and you know,
just being on top of them as well.
Let's call it what it,
is that what it is a lesbian than likes Dick?
I uh,
well I,
I think,
yeah.
Can you,
can you be an Alpha female and just be,
uh,
just a woman who's heterosexual,
but she just likes to be the boss.
So possible if course,
again,
of course everybody has their breaking point.
If you've been paying attention to this ban bossy campaign,
they've been paying attention to that.
You know,
I just got in town.
That's my answer.
Uh,
some feminists are trying to ban the word boss,
Dan.
I thought it was like band was one guy in Boston,
another and they were like,
okay.
I was trying to sound like real like for council member.
Yeah.
They're trying to ban the term bossy.
They think that,
well,
that word,
but there's nothing wrong with,
I'm super bossy and so is blank.
Well,
I think bossy is blanches her dog.
I think bossy is kind of a silly word.
Like,
well,
you beat all Bossy,
you know,
it's not like would he be a cunt?
You know what I'm saying?
No,
I,
if somebody's in a meeting,
we're like,
Eliza,
you're being bossy.
I,
it'd be funny if you said that in a corporate setting.
I think we have a real problem with,
uh,
the sexes,
with the battle between the men and the women.
And one of the big problems is that a lot of people are just shitheads and it's
just like making concessions to deal with shitheads,
whether it's male or female.
I think that's across the board for not even for me,
it's for race,
for socioeconomic things,
for everything.
It's just concession.
I think you're totally right.
I think that it's just dealing with a lot of shitheads,
but then there's like things that just throw you so out of whack,
like ban Bossy,
like,
well,
you gotta go,
come on.
You being so you guys are so crazy.
You were making the whole thing a parody.
It takes away the legitimacy from anything else that you have a problem with.
I can understand if bitch,
I hate that word.
And that my biggest defense,
if I ever get into a real argument,
if you ladies,
for the three of you listening a while,
you're at Jiu Jitsu black belt.
If you call a guy bitchy before he can call you bitchy,
you win there because there's no coming back from that.
Once you've like emasculated someone and you've been like,
you're being a bitch,
then they're like,
Whoa,
I got news for you.
If you can say you're being a bitch to a guy in your emasculating him,
he was lost from the start.
If a girl calls me a bitch,
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
Really?
What else?
Obviously it will stop me dead hanging out with her.
That's fair enough.
What are we doing?
But if you're having an argument,
like if for whatever,
I think if you were in the audience and you told someone quit being a bitch,
but am I pointing for their platform?
If they had said,
stop using the word bitchy or let's stop using other derogatory female words,
that's fine,
but bossy makes them sound like a bunch of fourth graders that want to run for
class president.
Well,
it sounds like what they're trying to do is just take away any even mildly
derogatory or mildly negative terms that could be applied to women that aren't
going to be applied to men because bossy doesn't seem,
it doesn't seem like you would use that in a master once.
I was going to say that.
Yeah.
It's totally not,
it's just for girls,
but it's also for little girls.
Like I would never describe a woman as bossy.
I'd say.
I'd probably just say she was bitchy to be quite frank.
But yeah,
it's not for guys because men are already bossy.
So I guess there in lies the problem.
Yeah.
If you had like a woman who was a boss,
like if she was the boss,
like a strong black woman,
a strong black woman,
and you're like,
well,
uh,
how was Shinya?
Is she a good boss?
And you'd be like,
she's a good boss,
but a tad Bossar right.
It's two totally different things.
That's how the ball,
it's a tad ball.
Say she's a dominant woman,
but a Tom Bossert smells her shit.
She's good at her job per Todd bullshit.
When I think Bossy,
I think micromanage.
I think of my mom at like Thanksgiving who like she brings an excel spreadsheet
to plan out thanksgiving.
No,
and some people does.
That's where you get it from.
I'm not that organized.
I go the other way.
I in the quietest way when I visit my family because my mom's like go,
go,
go.
Here's what we're doing.
She'll ask me months in advance about plane tickets.
I shut down.
I turned into like the biggest stoner attitude without partners.
Like I dunno man,
whatever happens cause she's so bossy that you can't,
you have no option but to go the other way or you will explode.
Isn't that funny how you see kids?
That there's a direct result of rebelling against their parents that's shaped
her personality?
Lot of kids like that?
Yeah.
Whether,
whether you mean to or not.
I mean I think my mom's great but I just,
I think also like energy wise,
like if you're an Alpha but you meet someone that's a super alpha,
like you can only have one super alpha.
Like I've met girls that are like,
I'm,
I'm kind of Bossy and I'm very like in control,
but when I meet other girls that are like,
that's all their personality,
I just get very quiet.
I'm like,
I'll just do whatever you want when you don't rip my tits
off.
Does that annoy you though?
Doesn't it annoy you when someone's Super Alpha or Super Bossy?
If I don't,
if I don't mind what we're doing.
Like I went to a wedding and there was this girl who was just like running shit
and she was telling everyone to do and I've been like one wedding ever so I was
fine to just do whatever she said because it's not my domain.
If it were something where I felt that I should be in charge than it would be
different.
Was this girl that bridesmaid or the sister of the bride or,
I think she was just one of the bridesmaids.
She was just a good run.
But I think part of being a comic also are being a human is identifying what
someone is and fully respecting that and rather than go against them sometimes
you know,
then you find out why they're like that.
She was dealing with some personal things.
So I was glad that I went with it versus butted up buddy.
I'm against her because it would've just,
it would've been a fight for no reason.
Does that make sense?
So fight for no reason is a good way to put it because that's what a lot of
people engage in.
They engage in these fights.
Like I've had conversations with friends where they'll tell me,
oh this fucking God said this and I was like,
fuck you.
And I fucking told him like,
I know what you're doing is passive aggressive bullshit is not going away.
And like at the end of the day,
man,
what do you care?
What do you mean it's not going to change?
It's funny,
he said nothing was accomplished,
nothing was accomplished.
They're not.
Especially as an adult,
like no one's gonna be like,
you really made me review my behavior.
She can,
but most of the times you can without going fuck you.
Most of the times you can by just talking to them and say,
hey man,
you know,
I respect too,
but this is how you're coming off to me.
I,
I had a thing recently was someone and I sent them an email and the best thing
to do is start out with,
if I've done something to offend you,
please let me know.
You start out like showing them your pink soft under belly.
And then that gives them a space to be like,
oh my God,
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to do it.
Like if you come from a place of contrition,
uh,
versus around playing yesterday,
you know when you get on a plane and you're like,
oops,
I didn't realize how drunk I was until I landed.
Like you'd get on the plane drunk from the night before where you really helped
getting her party on it.
They're on the road was one of those nights.
It's just like escalated very quickly.
What happened?
I just went out in Tampa with just some friends and I don't know why we were
drinking so much.
I don't know what happened.
Um,
but I had the one crazy,
it got crazy.
I just got really drunk.
Like I'm a plane.
I mean,
okay,
I'm sorry.
This is really bothered me.
And I'm in the fact that I was in first class is not the point of the story,
but I was in boarding group one and they bought it all the like one came
members,
global services is there,
like,
can I want,
so I let this woman go past me.
I go,
go ahead.
I'm not global service.
I'm not in any elite group.
I'm just in first class.
And she goes,
Oh,
well I'm going to first class too.
There's only 12 of us.
She was like,
just go ahead of me.
I go,
okay.
And this guy from behind me goes,
yeah,
don't worry about anyone else.
Just fucking do whatever you want to do.
And I thought he was joking,
like he was so angry and I was so buzz that like,
it wasn't sure,
like,
am I seeing things?
So I get on the plane,
I sit down and this guy made a point to when he walked on the plane to be
shaking his head at me when he got on the plane and every time I looked over to
like make sure he was real,
he would be shaking his head like I had done something and being a comic I then
the next three hours crafting the perfect comeback for when we got up cause I
was sure we were going to butt heads and like it was going to go down and the
plane landed and he got up and he walked off and I never got a chance to say
anything to him.
That's something not to get worked up about.
That's a weird one to get worked up about like letting someone go in front of
you,
being polite and [inaudible].
Although people,
I don't know why I think there's like a dark cloud over my head.
Like I just attract like negative energy.
I don't think so.
I've never seen it.
If there was a dark cloud over your head,
I think I want to notice that.
I think people just randomly like who gets,
I don't know,
maybe I just,
you,
um,
you're very strong personality and I mean that in a good way.
That's why you and I are such good friends because we're both strong
personalities because you,
you always say that about me,
but you're not like,
but like you're super cool about it.
Well,
I'm not,
I'm not offended by it.
I think some people are intimidated by,
well there's men that are certainly intimidated by women who were smart and
quick and have a strong personality.
Yeah.
Well I've sent it to you before.
Like,
I dunno what you do when you date.
Like it's gotta be rough out there for a chick like you.
I don't know either.
You got a lot,
a lot of,
um,
unusual attributes.
You're very smart and you're also very quick.
Like when I talk to you sometimes,
like I don't think I talk as quick as you most of the time.
And you're always like,
and I was like,
I felt like a Gremlin eating.
Yeah.
So it's like when,
when we have conversations with like,
Whoa,
I've got to pick up the pace here alive,
throwing heat.
You know,
like you're so excited to talk to you.
Well,
you were always,
you know,
you're fired up.
You're fired up person.
So fired up that.
But I think some men don't want that.
They want to check to just lay back.
Fair enough.
But take it.
What do you think that is?
Do you think that men are scared of competition?
Do you think that they're not secure in themselves so they don't like someone
who they might judge themselves against and go,
you know what?
I think my fucking girlfriends faster than me and she's smarter than me.
I think there's,
I think that's for guys or girls,
like nobody wants to feel threatened.
But I also think there's just different types of guys and there's secure guys
and there's insecure guys and some people also don't,
well,
I think everyone's a little insecure just as a human being mean.
The fact that we're vulnerable,
we're going to die.
We get diseases,
we get hit in the head by asteroids.
Shit happens.
You know?
Everyone's a little,
little bit insecure.
Sure.
But there's,
there's levels of that shit.
And I think that a girl who's just,
you don't look,
you have your dog,
you don't need anybody for love.
If you have a great career,
you don't need anybody for money,
you know,
you're pretty,
you can meet other guys.
It's like you got a lot of things that would fuck with a dude's head and you're
smart and fast.
That's gotta be tricky.
That'd be tricky.
I've,
I don't know.
And the older I get,
the more like I,
I think when you're in your 20s and you date,
you don't really think about it.
And now that I'm 31 I'm kind of looking back in hindsight and I'm like,
yeah,
maybe they did have an issue.
Like what starts off as not being an issue.
I think in the end becomes an issue for them.
But I don't,
any guy that I date is like very supportive because I don't date comics either.
So they're very supportive and they really respect what I do and I in turn
respect what they do.
You know,
you really have to respect what somebody else does.
I mean,
if you,
I could never date a that's sucked.
Even if he was a great person.
Because if you have a job and you are bad at your job,
like you actively bad at your job,
then it means that you're delusional.
Right?
That means you're crazy.
And it's like if you don't like my stand,
that's one thing.
But there are plenty of people that do versus I'm a musician,
I had can't get a record deal.
My is always out of tune and like this is my passion.
I'd be like,
okay,
well then you take your passion,
you can go to the third tree,
prominent author because I keys.
That means there are other areas in your life where that where you being that
inept is gonna is gonna do is going to harm you.
I agree.
And I think that people that are really bad at something and don't realize that
they're really bad at something that's a sign of,
there's a,
there's like a,
there's something wrong.
It's like a pathology there,
I think.
But I also think they're lucky in a weird way,
like ignorance is bliss.
Like they're just super hot.
Like people are so happy.
I don't buy that shit.
I don't buy it at all.
They're not.
It's not.
There's no bliss.
There's failure.
They're nothing but failure.
They can never get it together.
I think that's just the opposite of being lucky.
Think people are happy or think they're really good when they're not good.
I think that was probably one of the worst things that could ever befall a human
being because you think they secretly know they might.
I don't think they do know.
Even if they don't know.
I have a conversation with comics.
I think they're good and I know they fucking suck.
I know they suck and they think they're good and you'll talk to them about sets
and they bombed and they'll tell you that it went great.
What are you about that?
Because I've had that happen where a lot to like a friend.
Yeah.
Or he'll be like,
I crushed it.
And then someone else would be like,
yeah,
I saw.
I said it was,
it was terrible.
So then you're,
you're faced with,
you're like,
who's the crazy person here?
Are you lying to me or are you delusional?
Are you,
do you know that you suck but you deep down or do you really deep down think
you're really good but you had to be like what's going on and why am I the only
one seeing it?
You see it's just like we were talking about before,
that type of personality can manifest itself in a bunch of different ways and
this is just one example of it there.
It'll show up in a bunch of different parts of their life.
It's not just that,
but a lot of it is revisionist history.
They'll Dell have a bad set and then go back over their head and find things
about the set that were good and then convince themselves that it was good.
See I wish I had that ability cause I'll have a good set.
So here's why.
Because all have a good set and I'll go back and I'll find all the bad things.
I'll be like,
that was horrible.
That's because you're an artist,
an artist.
That's what's called someone who is care.
So wouldn't it be nice to give yourself a break once in a while?
No,
no.
It's like you get better.
I completely agree.
I don't know why I'm playing this like passive passive hippie role.
I just deal with it.
I,
I look,
I can crush,
I can have a standing ovation and I'll fuck up one joke and then she will haunt
me for days for Denver and every comic knows like the one guy in the front row
who's mentally damaged.
That can't laugh,
but it's sitting in the front row and you don't know that they're retarded till
later and you're like,
he wasn't laughing.
Oh,
I don't pay attention to that.
That I don't pay attention.
If you don't laugh,
that's on you.
You could choose not to laugh at a lot of things in life,
but what I,
it's like at this stage in my life,
I know when I'm out of tune and I've been out of tune before and I fucking hate
that feeling and that shit will drive me crazy.
But I always feel like I get better because of that.
If I have a,
yeah,
if I have a moment where I'm out of tune and it haunts me,
it makes me work harder.
It makes me go back to the notebooks.
It makes me go back to the,
to the,
to the keyboard.
That's the other thing for like comics,
if it was comics listening,
I always have,
cause I always come up and they was asking you,
you know what?
What's the secret of what do you do?
And I'm like you need to stop talking to me.
And did you get on stage?
You need to stop writing and like doing your act in the mirror.
Like you need to get onstage and fail and fail and fail.
And when that joke sucks 10 times in a row,
do it 10 more times in a row.
It's repetition.
It's just like being an athlete and people don't get that right.
When this is what,
just what we were talking about,
the people that don't see it,
the nurses,
bliss people,
they're not going to get those lessons.
No,
there'll be terrible for sure.
Forever.
I don't know why I said that.
What you just trying to alleviate a little bit of the tension that find some
happiness.
Yeah,
I uh,
yeah,
but we can't,
there's comfort in discomfort.
You can learn from them.
That's the good place.
I like being uncomfortable.
I think some of the best moments on stage or when you ignore,
I mean,
and audiences love it when something bombs and you're like,
this is,
you guys deserved a better ending than that.
And I'm sorry,
I'm sorry I came at you with that you paid taking home,
you're free improv glasses and I shouldn't have.
Well that's one of the best ways to get through a new bit and you go like,
that bit is not done.
It needs work.
That's a trick that we all do.
Yeah.
Or I've said that the other day I did a whole bit and it had this great
crescendo and everything and there,
right where there should have been like the killer punch line.
I was just like,
this bit needs were.
I was like,
I'm sorry I took you on that journey,
but wasn't it fun?
Isn't it funny though that the only way to really work on those bits besides the
writing and the stuff that you do by herself,
as you got to do it in front of people and tweak it in front of people,
guys,
you got to get up and you gotta just do it.
There is no right.
I mean you can write all you want.
We'll are,
we have the one of the weirdest art forms because it's one of the only art forms
that comes to life and develops in front of people.
You could develop a killer fucking song by yourself and you can say,
Hey,
I wrote this song and you play it.
It's done.
You know,
you could play it for me.
And I'd be like,
Holy Shit,
that's a great fucking song.
But it's kind of rare.
It happens occasionally.
There's some bits that just write themselves and then they're done right out of
the gate.
But it's,
most of the time they,
they come alive in front of people and then you edit them in front of people and
you change them.
And then you know,
you love those two show,
Friday two shows Saturday week.
So you're really good.
By the time the late show,
Saturday rolls around,
you've got a good sense of how that bit works.
And it's,
it's,
it's also because it's ever evolving and it's a living thing.
And the bit,
I mean you could have a bit that you said like it's pretty,
I won't say perfect,
but it is the way it is.
You've been doing the same but it's ever changing and you're always tweaking it.
You're always fixing a little bit.
It's never perfect,
which is what makes it frustrating but also so fun.
Yeah.
I'm glad you said that.
Cause that's how I always describe it.
I always describe comedy as like a living art form.
It is,
it's like alive.
It's alive and it's like a little animal.
I like taking her exam.
I think it,
most things a little animals,
but it's right in front of,
and it's different with each audience.
There's no,
I say that some of the other day,
what's weird about comedy is that if you were looking at it scientifically,
there is no control group.
There's never a point where you're like,
this joke existed in this perfect vacuum and here's how it should be.
And then you test it on different audiences.
It's difficult to tame because it's different every single time and your
variables change every time.
Yeah.
But that's cause you're good people that are not good.
We've all seen them.
They start out the same way every night.
They end the same way every night.
They press play,
click,
and they have an act.
Yeah.
To just play that act,
it was the hardest lesson I had to learn at the beginning when I would do the
comedy store because I have a very energetic act and so whatever I had for the
first,
whatever 20 minutes I had when I first started,
I would do that and I would just pound the audience with it.
Not giving sound.
I can't believe I'm talking about this room,
but not giving it a chance to breathe.
Not,
you know,
Tommy at the comedy store,
like I sound like him.
Right?
Why does he say that?
Well,
I'm gonna get your Bates Ryan Chi.
It's a living.
You have to,
you have to.
You don't talking about,
I know he doesn't ever talk to me about,
I haven't talked to him in seven years,
but even back then he doesn't talk to me about a comma.
No.
And he wouldn't be doing it now for sure.
He imparts this wisdom anyway,
but he w I W I can't.
What I'm saying is he was right in that.
You got to
Brian.
Oh,
it's like a fine wine.
You know.
Missy knows and I know how to tell people.
You build a lot of prey,
but it,
you get up there,
you got to let the audience,
you got to gauge them.
Give it a second.
Like I had to learn.
I can't just go on stage and be like,
how's everybody doing?
So pizza.
Yeah,
sometimes you can sometimes,
yeah,
sometimes you cannot.
And when you find that connection with the audience and then you ride that wave.
I was on the plane coming home from Orlando and I listened to something that I'm
going to recommend that every comedian,
it's pretty fucking bad ass.
Um,
it's a laugh.com thing.
I thought it was a woody Allen standup bit and a or a standup album.
He goes,
I don't,
you know,
I've only seen a few pieces of woody Allen stuff.
I really haven't listened to a much of his comedy.
And uh,
I'm incredibly fascinated by him as a human being just because all of the above.
Cause he's a creeper.
Yeah.
Cause he's talented as well because he,
he's really funny.
And he was,
and I listened to some of his old stuff and it was really like hypersexual and I
was like,
wow,
I never really noticed how sexual it was.
And I'm like,
no wonder why he's such a fucking purse.
But it's woody Allen on comedy and it's from laugh.com.
It's really fucking old.
I think it might be from before he was even doing movies because there's no
mention of movies and it's mentioned of like Jack Benny and Jackie Gleason and
old school comics that I've never heard of before.
And his,
uh,
his voice sounds really young.
That's cool.
I listen to that.
It's really interesting because it's just,
it's not comedy.
It's just a question and answer piece on.
That's it right there.
Woody Allen on comedy and um,
uh,
if you're a cop,
look,
it's got 1203 reviews,
five star reviews.
It's really fucking good.
Yeah.
Um,
I just looked on,
you know,
the Google play store or Amazon MP3 store and just downloaded it.
I was just looking for something woody Allen on a whim and a listen to it for
the first time this weekend.
It's really fucking interesting because first of all he's dead on the money
about a lot of shit,
but he's really honest too about like hacks and about how some people can like
really kill but the audience takes nothing from it.
And then someone else might have like a little less of an impact like laugh
wise.
But the audience walks away and they're like really intrigued and feel touched
and connected by what that person said.
You know,
I can think of a perfect example of that is like Bill Hicks.
Like there's some people that think bill Hicks is the most hilarious guy ever.
I completely disagree.
I,
he's one of my all time favorite comedians without a doubt.
And one of my all time,
most influential people that I've ever seen perform and that I've ever listened
to and a hero of mine for sure.
But I don't think he's the funniest guy ever.
I don't even need,
yes,
I feel that way about bill burr,
who I think is a genius and I think he's hilarious.
But when I listen to his stuff,
it's less than,
I mean this in and from the highest light.
I guess it's less than me laughing out loud,
more,
more me going like,
oh my God,
that is such a good,
I think that's cause you're a comic because you like,
yeah.
Appreciate the craft of his comics.
He makes me laugh my fucking ass off.
Um,
first of all,
I love bill because he's a,
from where I'm from,
he's old school.
Boston.
Yeah.
Like if you want to know like what's a Boston style of comedy?
His style was more Boston even than mine.
Sure.
It's like hyper observational in your face.
I would just call it east coast.
Yes.
I mean,
cause then you have someone like on the other end of the spectrum like Pablo
Francisco,
who I fucking worship.
And that's not,
you don't walk away from that.
Like,
oh,
that's a real thinker.
That's true for a bit.
But God was that fucking funny.
Well,
he's all noises,
silliness.
I love his own eyes,
Pablo and person too,
to really appreciate the madness.
Like,
oh,
seem Pablo on television.
And it's like you don't,
I'm trying to figure out what my next special,
how to,
uh,
get a live performance to translate directly into a DVD or a CD.
And I think the best way when I'm going to do my next one,
I'm gonna do it in a comedy club,
a real small,
like 300 seat comedy club.
Because I've been doing these 2000 seat venues and it's not the same man man
doing those huge venues.
It's just not the same.
The connection with the crowd,
not as intimate.
I've always wanted to do a double released DVD.
I'd like to do not the same set,
but like you'd tell them together and one would be the big venue,
like a theater and then one would be something like,
not a Largo but something more intimate.
And you could is Largo seat?
I don't know.
I've never been allowed in uh,
like a hundred.
I don't know.
It's,
it's small.
It's smaller than have in Margo got a club.
Is that a click?
It's like super cool.
Is it super cool?
It's not super cool though.
It's like we're a band,
but we don't play music.
We just write down the notes and then we fax them like,
I don't know.
Well it's a part of the alternative comedy movement.
Tis but perform there.
But I've always wanted to sell to DVDs.
Just almost just to showcase your range as a comic.
Like,
look,
I can do an intimate
room or dominate with a big room.
Yeah,
that's a,
that it's a totally different style comedy,
right?
Holy cause you can't come out,
you can't be in everyone's face in a small room.
It's all you have to connect with the audience.
It's,
it's like it's two different animals.
There's that feeling that you get to when you're in a comedy club,
like uh,
when you're in the back of the room,
like the smile is very contagious.
It's like you're overwhelmed by the positive energy of the room when it's doing
well and like to like to the laugh factory or not the laugh factor,
whether the ice house is my favorite example,
the ice house,
that main room is only seats when it's stuffed to the gills and only gets 190
people in there.
It's tiny and it just,
it just lights up.
It's just on fire when you're in the middle of that versus being on a stage
that's far away from them.
I actually,
if I had my job,
if I can make a living doing my comedy is very loud and in your face and
energetic so it lends itself to a larger room.
But I really enjoy my small alternative venues.
I love doing them cause that you get that connectivity and you write the most
and you get a chance to be like,
was that funny?
Did you like that?
And like you can see the disgust on their face and right up close.
Do you ever do the little stage of the Ice House?
The the stage two?
Yeah.
That place is the shit.
I like 85 90 seats or something.
I've done that when I've done your show and that's cool.
I just just,
it's just a different kind of writing and I think a good comic can go from one
to the other,
can run off and go do it.
300 person show at the Improv and then run to that small stage and adjust
accordingly.
I agree.
And I think it's a really interesting thing and news parallels I think in all
art forms,
whether it's in music or in painting or anything,
everyone that I've talked to that's an artist about creating the creative
process and it seems to be all about just like focusing on it,
the intensity and the focus and the dedication you have to whatever you're
doing,
whether it's uh,
completing a set,
writing a joke or making a sculpture,
whatever the fuck it is,
it's like getting out of the way and focusing on it,
but yet getting yourself out of the way and letting that thing become whatever
the fuck it is.
It's,
it's a,
it's a process and it also takes time to even learn that process.
Like joke aside,
like to know I need to let this breathe or I need to think about this.
Like there's just,
and there's no right or wrong way to do it.
It's almost like you're lost in a comedy forest and you've got to like figure
out your own way back when you have,
when you're onstage and you've got this like list of jokes that you're trying to
work out or the beats and there's no right way to put that set list and an
order.
It's like a weird science.
Yeah.
And it's a weird science and no one can fucking teach you.
You cannot be taught.
That's my other thing.
I have a friend who's a comedy coach and she's hilarious.
So she is the exception to this rule.
But in general,
like that's why most people that like teach comedy classes,
it's like you've never heard them have them because those who can't do and those
who can't teach,
um,
because we can do,
and those who can't teach,
but you can't be taught all these comedy classes,
comedy lectures,
comedy seminars,
and even right now,
like you can listen to us all you want,
but at the end of the day,
if you don't get up tonight and do
like those three minutes that scare you,
you're never going to be anything.
I agree with you wholeheartedly,
but I think where it benefits is someone who's listening to this can get the
Eliza slessinger take on on comedy and apply it,
learn from their own real career,
blah,
put it in their database.
And like I was saying about Woody Allen on comedy,
I mean,
I've been doing comedy for 20 fucking something years and listening to Woody
Allen on comedy,
I was like,
Ooh,
okay.
Oh right.
You should listen to everyone.
You should take notes.
You should watch comics that you like.
But at the end of the day,
if you don't practice yes that it's worthless.
Blogger comedy blogger,
will the,
have you ever seen people that raped my DVD?
Just saying random.
Have you ever seen a comedy?
Bloggers try to go on stage and they think they're cute.
No,
but he plays a shit of course.
And then you want to be like,
let me review your performance asshole,
who we started out where you can finish them weaker.
Well,
it's one of those things where you can't,
there's no shortcuts to doing stand up.
No one can teach you how to do it.
But what we can show catch,
you can get a horrible show and then you can sell out arenas.
The rest of,
there's no shortcuts.
When you go up there,
you still eat shit that's even more frightening.
That's the Michael Richard Scenario.
When you were a hugely famous,
very successful world,
loved math and then you go on stage and eat plates of Shit.
Well he was saying the n word because he was,
first of all,
I called,
I'm pretty sure he was coked up.
And I say this is a person who's never done coke.
So I don't really totally know the coke attitude other than like watching it
from afar.
But uh,
you've been blanche up to the microphone is not,
you can't keep her away from you for just a few minutes.
I would,
I speaking
she's a little sweetie.
Um,
Michael Richards was at the comedy store before he had his famous meltdown that
night at the laugh factor.
He had two sets that night and Brent Ernst came up to me,
um,
after the laugh factory one.
Yeah,
he came over to the stores.
Like,
dude,
I just saw the craziest shit cause he was there.
He's like,
he goes,
that fucking Michael Richards guy goes on stage,
the laugh factory is eating shit.
These black guys started heckle him.
He starts tossing around the end bomb.
I go,
no.
He goes,
yes.
look there's a nigger.
And he starts pointing at them and sang it and Brent Arts is saying this and
we're like holding her face.
The of out of the store were like no he didn't.
I guess he did but I thought it was going to end there and then someone fucking,
it was like one of the very first time someone filmed something with their
camera.
But we watched Michael Richards have these really tough sets and it was really
weird because he's this guy super famous and he would go onstage and just
fucking bomb.
He had nothing.
He was an open miker me,
he was an open mic or that was super confident and he would get these big rounds
of applause when he'd get on the stage.
Like everybody be so excited.
And then he would like to prat falls and it,
but it would never translate without the rest
of the cast without a writer.
Right.
I mean that's a thing about sitcoms.
It's like a re sitcom writers are some of the most undervalued and
underappreciated people in the world of like making those stars.
Like there's a whole slew of people that are,
you know,
they may,
might not ever be great comics themselves,
but they know how to craft material for a guy like Richard was.
Is it Ray Romano or is it Jerry Seinfeld that's someone says,
I think about like how you're given that x amount of minutes when you get
onstage,
when you're someone phases.
Yeah,
they give you,
they give you that and that's what the applause on the courtesy labs because
they're waiting for something good.
I've seen plenty of comics who are movie stars maybe started as comics and then
became something else and they go back and you're like,
this is horrible.
Or I was talking about this with somebody last night.
I'll have people that I think are very funny.
And then on Twitter it doesn't translate.
And I think a versatile comic that he was between a standup comedian and a funny
person is somebody that is able to be ver to do it on any platform.
You can be funny in person or in the writing or 140 characters or on a script.
Like that's when you have comedy in you man,
your performer versus muscle that you're kind of comedy like some,
some kinds of comedy just do not translate in the written form.
Some don't.
And that's the example.
Like here's Michael Richards.
You're not a standup comic.
Maybe did it at one point,
but people think,
and this is not about him,
but I think that's where ego gets into it cause you're like,
Whoa,
I'm fucking funny.
When people write my stuff down,
I could do this.
So many people and it drives me to take my art form that I hold near and dear to
me and that standup comedy.
And they're like,
I could do that.
Hey,
I'm doing standup now.
I'm like,
Oh are you?
Or is it doing you?
Oh are,
oh,
you're just going to give it a whirl.
Okay,
cool.
That's like,
it's almost like it's my,
it's my craft and very protective of,
of all that it entailed.
Use exclusive like to tell in a,
do you feel like exclusionary like that?
Do you think like what do you mean?
Like I have the tea,
the totally opposite attitude.
Like if someone says a,
I think I could do that.
I'm going to do standup comedy.
I'm like,
you could do it.
Anyone can do it.
You can do it.
You just have to figure it out.
If your objective,
you can figure it out.
I don't begrudge anyone the,
and I want them to go up there and be funny.
I love funny people.
I think my thing is people say it as if like I'm going to take a pottery
workshop,
like I'm going to give standup oral and it's almost this,
I've had friends or I've known people that have done it and they eat shit that
they thought they did a good job or they're like,
this is part of my thing.
I'm like,
I want these jokes to be weird.
And you're like,
all right.
So what just happened was the,
you just killed the energy that I've got to go dig myself out of a fucking hole.
Now my four year old does that.
Like she'll fall down and go,
I meant to do that.
The quicker you get over the fact that everyone falls and you should never lie
because everyone knows that you fell.
Moral is don't be a liar.
Don't try to trick people to make yourself feel better because it doesn't ever
work.
It's like name dropping that shit.
No one,
no one never has never will.
It just makes you look like a fucking idiot,
you know,
like,
well,
you know,
we're hanging out with David Copperfield the other night and like no one,
no one gives a fuck.
Nobody gives us,
not only do they not give a fuck,
they respect you less for namedropping the old and what is tough,
I will say this on the rare occasion that I'm with somebody that is famous or
that is like cool.
I almost,
because I was so painfully sell for,
I preface it with,
I'm not trying to sound like a jerk,
like whatever Brad Pitt is not the guy in the store,
but Brad Pitt was there.
I don't know him.
He was at the party.
Here's the rest of the story.
It's letting you know that like we don't hang out,
but I was next to bribery.
You being aware,
being aware of how Douchey it could sound to name drop Brad Pitt,
whereas a person who's unaware,
unaware people are really frustrating to me.
Like people are just lucky.
I'm just kidding.
The frustrating goofiness of being unaware is it's very,
to me it bothers me because,
um,
I think that all comics in WWE in some way or form or kind of chameleons,
I think we sort of,
uh,
we,
we sort of absorb a lot of,
like a lot of who I am.
Like what,
what makes me like a comic is like a lot of funny people that I knew,
people that I grew up with,
people that I ran into that said funny things.
And I've sort of like,
I think all of us sponge,
I mean that's just even the most unique personality ever uses the English
language and uses it in a form that people have used for thousands of years.
I mean it's like even the combination of words that you use that are
particularly unique,
you use it because you've sort of seen a million different examples of how other
people use the English language and you've kind of like taking a little bit of
this and added a little bit of that and always a combination of Jackie Gleason
and Sam Kennison and you know,
I think that hyper awareness kind of takes the wonder out of,
or it's always takes the mystery out of people.
Like even if we were to like talk about like even in the dating world,
some guy walks in and he's got like,
like a Johnny Depp thing,
like maybe like a bunch of necklaces and like a shirt open.
I'm like,
you purposefully put on all those necklaces,
you're not a pirate.
When I see like punk rockers and they've got like a Mohawk and I'm like,
I'm just imagining this super tough punk rock or sitting there with hair putty
for four hours sculpting this and it just takes the mystique out of all of it.
Cause you have to think about it.
Think about it.
No one is original.
Everything is horrible.
Can I?
Well you can be original or you can be uniquely you,
but you're not a hundred percent original.
It's impossible.
And so we come from a culture that has existed for hundreds of years and it's a
part of a civilization,
human civilization that's existed for thousands of years.
And there's just no getting away from that.
You can't get out of your roots.
You're not going to be wholly and completely unique.
Uh,
I actually am working on,
this is also a comic thing,
like prefacing it with working on a bit about,
but girls and men do it too obviously.
But like girls have this when you are part of a homogeneous mixture of people,
like,
and when you go to high school where everyone's blonde,
everyone's chill,
everything's says girls always find that,
have this desire to set themselves apart.
And it's always something like I'm one 18th Cherokee,
my mom
was Spanish and it's just like you are white.
Nobody cares.
And it's this desire to set ourselves apart.
Cause we're always told that we're special and we're different.
Right?
So that's,
you know,
or even like,
oh,
your last name is whatever.
Like,
Oh Donald.
And you're like,
yeah,
Irish pride.
And it's like your great,
great grandmother was Irish.
Like that's it.
You've never been nothing about use,
particularly Irish.
I can drink just as much as you like.
People love that.
They'll look to their heritage to separate them.
And when that doesn't do it,
they'll look to where they were born or where they were conceived.
Anything to set them apart.
My friend Marcus Davis,
he's a fighter.
He used to fight for the UFC in these a yacht.
It's pretty hot.
Is good looking man.
Alright,
so studly manly man.
But,
uh,
he's from Maine and,
he's a Boston main area and he's,
um,
you know,
grew up,
I think at Boston lives in May now cause he just likes it up there.
But Very Irish like into Irish would,
he would fight,
would go out to the house of pain,
you know,
and you know,
like a painter as well.
What Irish people
jump up,
jump up again.
We've heard it four times when we play something else.
One more time.
Slowly.
Yeah.
Acoustic version.
And um,
anyway,
he fought another friend of mine,
Dan Hardy,
who's a,
an English man,
a real English might like from England and uh,
Dan Hardee was mocking him,
calling him a fake Irishman,
you know,
I was like,
he's like half Irish,
like claiming I,
and he just mocked him the entire campus.
Fager and by the time they got into the cage together,
he was so angry.
He was so pissed at Dan because Dan was calling him a fake.
Marcus was just out of his head.
Like he didn't,
didn't fight up to his potential just because he was so emotional.
He didn't use it.
While he just couldn't,
well it's not,
you don't really know.
The Irish aren't very bright.
No,
that's totally the things I said.
That's the one we were like,
no,
please don't think that we have a thing against the Irish.
Emotions are your enemy.
And when it comes to fighting,
when you a,
when you get too vested in,
you know,
the,
the pressure of kicking someone's ass,
it just can be,
it's too much.
It makes it,
it makes it,
but I would imagine,
have you ever had a little hair puller?
A fucking no.
I went to college.
I'm not going to get people in college fight.
I think if you are not a real fighter,
I'm want,
see,
I'm speaking to women.
It is the ultimate white trash move to get in a fight.
Really?
Yeah.
Because that means my words that I use to make a living and feed my dog have
exhausted me and um,
I,
I'm going to have to resort to violence.
How much you've gotten me.
I don't understand that mentality.
If you're a real fire,
I guess that's different cause that's what you would go to.
Or probably if you're real far do,
you would never find anyone randomly because you have too much to lose and you
could probably kill them.
Well also you realize how dumb it is.
It's,
it's,
it's dumb,
you know,
would fighting,
well not fighting.
Let me fight with fighting.
Really is is like what fighting is with animals.
It's just like it's combat,
but when you're thinking about martial arts,
martial arts,
the,
the last person that you would expect to see in a fight as a martial artist,
right?
A smart martial artists would be able to figure out way out of the situation
long before it ever escalated.
Most likely,
unless you're just in the worst case scenario with the worst aggressive drunks
and dangerous people and you've got to defend yourself.
Two things.
One,
I'm slightly obsessed with Ronda Rousey and I follow her and slightly every time
I see you,
you're like,
I got to be right because she is like,
I think I'm pretty tough girl,
but like she takes it to a hold of,
she'll make you uncomfortable.
She's so cool,
but I feel like we'll be best friends anyway.
I wrote a bit about her.
Did you look it up?
How about the next time you come on I'll bring Rhonda.
I really want that because I have so many things to tell her.
Also,
I think she's really pretty and I follow Instagram and I'm really excited that
careers,
the back of your hair,
you will never see a fight or get taken down quicker than if she tried to kiss
me,
you would take her down on the rousing.
So what I'm saying,
she know.
Why would she kiss me just to fucking dominate,
you know,
just to go Alfon you know you're a really strong chick and think it works that
way for women gets bigger right here.
Oh my fucking God.
Long Gates like
they're not going to listen to it anyway.
The guy from fear factor.
I love that show.
Did you know that?
I mean is the female Hyena actually fake penis?
They have a pho penis,
doesn't it all start as a vagina and then it grows into a vignette like China.
The wrestler has like a giant sort of,
what you're saying is very similar.
We all what it is is we all start out as females.
Human beings do it.
Yeah.
That's why men have nipples.
Right.
Um,
I just,
I had another point before we start talking about eight clutter clutter.
I were talking about hyenas.
No we were not.
You were talking about drowsy.
You made it weird.
Won't say Rhonda would grow at giant fake dig if she's around you just to
dominate you.
Okay.
I just want to meet her cause I think we'd be like best friends and I just want
to like maybe like train with her one day but not have anyone touch me at the
same time.
But she would show you some moves.
You wouldn't roll with her.
But she moves.
She's so cool.
Well I'm glad you love her.
You know,
she's a really unique person.
It's like Dana White and I were having this conversation once and he was like,
she's just a once in a lifetime person.
I said,
no,
I go more than that.
I go,
she's a once ever.
there's never would think about how many lifetimes people have lived.
What's the other Ronda Rousey's you can bring it up.
So if I were a girl that if I were a fire,
if I did like ultimate fighting like her,
I would be scared shitless.
She just dominates consistently.
She doesn't lose.
And I looked at a picture on her Instagram and it's who she fighting a fight
coming up in like in May and let us Davis.
Yeah,
and like the picture like Rhonda,
obviously it's like she's a star now and she's got like a makeup team and her,
she's got her heavyweight belt and her hair is done.
The other girls didn't like a sports bra from like a big five,
like no team around her,
no lighting.
She does have a theme.
Davis is a very talented fighter.
She's really good.
It's a good fight.
I beat my Rhonda.
I liked to fight though because Davis has a black belt in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
She's got real good Moy Tai,
great leg kicks.
She's very technically sound,
say all of us,
but Rhonda has just,
she's such a fucking beast.
She's,
she's a weird combination because she's absolutely beautiful,
but she,
she's just so fucking physically dominant,
you know,
it's not just pretty but with great technique and you know,
wins but looks like a girl.
Like she's got this weird thing going on where she like crosses back and forth
between,
you know,
like just like a werewolf,
she crosses back and forth between like bad ass monster and hot chick.
Yeah.
Thick neck but still pretty.
She's still,
she's able to do it.
She's,
she's,
she pulls it off.
I've got nothing.
Even if it hasn't been bad decide wouldn't she,
she also owns who she is and she owns it.
Hook,
line and sinker.
Like this is who it is.
Take it or go fuck yourself.
Well I think she is also,
I mean she gets to play herself and movies like she's going to be,
what's the movie she spendable?
Spendable is like,
she's a fighter and these,
you know,
they're not asking her to play like she's not in a romantic comedy.
She's been given the blessing of getting to be herself in her career so early on
versus trying to be something else.
Well,
she has a very unique mother.
Her mother was one of the very first medalists in,
in,
in judo and she was a world championship level judo player.
Her mom was exactly the same.
Her family,
your family.
So her,
her mom is a very unique woman.
Really,
really into,
I want to get her on the podcast and I will eventually,
but her mom is brilliant.
I've really,
really intelligent and he just developed her daughter,
you know,
early on like she would wake her up in the middle of night and make her do
armbars.
She's just like wake her up,
get on top of her and make Rhonda hit an Armbar.
I created a monster.
Yeah,
she did.
But an awesome monster.
Yeah.
I enjoy that chick personnel.
We can be best friends.
When I get French fries,
I'll,
I'll hook you guys up.
I'll get the phone numbers together and make it happen.
Me,
Brian Collins matter and he said I can meet her.
You met her.
That's it.
Those are my only friends that come on.
We can make it real.
I really want to meet her.
Okay.
I will make you meet her and arm wrestle her.
No,
you don't want that.
I'll show you when we leave.
I mean anything competitive with her.
Just how do we both do standups.
He fucking wins.
Rhonda.
She's good.
She probably is.
She's probably one of those that's like everything she like bake a pie wall.
Don't style opening the door.
Oven door.
Could you imagine if she got on stage and fucking kill that would really
devastate,
you know,
just one home and write jokes?
I would,
no.
I would know because I would,
I would just be like,
I would solidify my desire to be best friends with her.
If you were on an island together,
do you think you'd go lesbian with her?
No.
She would eat me,
eat my face,
and she would pick my teeth with her arms.
What if you were like a,
you know,
an island with a lot of good food?
A lot of fish.
First of all,
I'm not a dude,
so my desire to fuck is not as intense as a man's.
My thing would be like,
I need to stay alive and eat versus like,
oh,
I got to fuck someone.
Hey,
other woman,
let's do it now.
I would not.
But you would like to opinion ship.
At least I think the
desire would become an family.
No,
but the desire to like be touched.
It's very universal,
right?
It's so universal.
I definitely,
yeah,
it,
yes.
I was thinking about it this weekend.
I definitely made someone give me a back rub quite in backrub.
It will also just a hug.
Just someone giving you a hug if you haven't been hugged in a while.
However,
to the guys listening,
don't hug girls that don't want to be hugged.
Yeah,
don't do that.
That's creepy.
Yeah.
Well,
especially girls because a guy hugging a girl,
it's such an,
it's a risky scenario for the girl on,
well not always,
but the pot,
the potential is there and it's just a risky scenario that you're going to let
this guy hold your body.
And then also it's like,
then it escalates with a lot of people.
Then it moves to like creepier and creepier and creepier is,
some guys can give you a hug,
right?
And it's just a hug like,
Hey Eliza,
what's up?
I hope that I'm that guy.
I give you hugs and you don't get any weirder.
Like he's trying to get hugged number three.
Now he's trying to rob his crotch or grounds.
But there are guys like that,
right?
Sure.
I can get that first hug and then after,
well,
uh,
I get a lot of like,
comics will come up that I don't know,
but they think we know each other,
which is,
look,
I'm not famous and I'm not a dick,
but like just cause I did one show with you.
Right?
Like ever or just cause I've seen you at the comedy store in they come to be
like what up sweetheart?
And they give you a hug and you're like,
ugh.
Like I don't want to hug you.
Like I don't want to get a physical connection with you fucking I don't,
I don't know you.
My thing is after shows and this is always wearing me out.
I've had definitely,
I've got all kinds of fans,
a lot of creepy ones,
a lot of lonely ones.
Everybody's super cool.
I've never had an issue with a male fan being aggressive even if they're like
wasted.
But I've definitely had girls that get out of control like Lesbos style.
Like I had a girl,
she kept kissing my face.
Like she kept kissing my cheek and like a security guide intervene.
Like I could definitely take care of myself cause she wasn't Ronda Rousey but
it's always weird like girls step over that line more than guys do but they
definitely like touch you.
We're like on your side and they want to see like are you fat under that t
shirt?
Like girls do that guys,
you had to like there's,
when you take a picture,
they put their arm around your waist and I'm just like hyper aware of the fact
that there is a very thin fabric separating like my naked body from this guy's
hand and you're wondering when is he going to go back and be like,
oh yeah,
she wasn't as fit as I thought.
She'd be like,
you just all these thoughts and meanwhile they're just drunk and like I gotta
get Outta here.
But,
but you attach all these things to it course touching my body.
There's a weird thing where you,
where people hug girls.
Like hugging a girl is like pretty standard.
You know,
if you know a girl and you see her like,
Hey,
what's up?
You hugging it.
Whereas like if as a dude that I knew the same amount,
I wouldn't shake his hand,
but you'd hug like you're a good guy friends.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I have all my friends.
I hugged every life.
If I see Joey Diaz,
I hug him.
Every time I see him
there's a,
there's a certain line you cross.
And then once you become huggers,
you must maintain hugging.
Yeah.
You can't like hug,
hug,
hug.
Hey,
nice to meet you and shake your hand or nice to see.
Yeah.
I'm not a big hugger with some of my,
most with my closest girlfriends we don't hug cause we're just not like that.
I tend to hug girls that I know less because it lets them know like look,
I'm a girl.
Like right.
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
Like you're almost like like throwing up a flag of peace and friendship and it's
also a good way like,
I don't know,
to break the ice after if you go to like a party,
like it was nice meeting you.
Right,
right,
right.
It's just a human thing to do.
Like to solidify that the,
it was a fun sort of like put a cap on it that it was a good interaction.
But I've definitely done like this weird autism thing where like all hug,
like three of the four people in the forest one just be like,
I do that too.
If I don't know the other person where sometimes they'll go,
come on,
bring it in.
Let's all hug group hug.
Really what I'm,
the subtext is like,
I just gotta get Outta here,
so please don't think I'm going goodbye.
Right.
So what did that one person,
that shit will haunt them?
Like you stumbling on a joke,
a fourth person that you didn't hug.
What the fuck do I fucking,
Shit.
I was listening to this thing.
It was a talk once that this guy was giving about,
um,
uh,
all sorts of different psychological disorders in one of them was a theory that
they had had at one point in time about schizophrenia,
schizophrenia being,
um,
having something to do with smells.
And that will,
that you give off certain,
that it's a form for mono will issue that you give off a certain smell and then
people respond to that smell and they go,
oh,
this guy's weird.
And then you go,
wow,
I'm fucking weird.
And then it starts this chain reaction that makes you weird,
that makes you yourself pheromones upset someone else.
Yeah.
Because you're,
your reality becomes defined by people avoiding you and freaking out by you and
you can get kind of crazy because of that.
It sounds like you need to be sensitive,
right people and even be more secure in who they are.
Whoa,
look at you.
Fucking take that.
Hey,
we all,
we all start from different places.
Allows us this last year some people had shitty homes without organized parents
like you.
I fair enough.
I think the schizophrenia,
I think the pheromone thing is huge.
I have dated,
I remember dating someone,
we didn't really have anything in common,
but we couldn't stop smelling each other well went to a bar and I just buried my
face in his neck and I just like,
I can't stop.
There was something,
some people just smell like home for some reason.
Not necessarily your home,
but like you get a very comfortable feeling.
He's turned out to be a nightmare.
But on a fairly low level.
It was so he was a nightmare.
A nightmare psychologically.
I mean it was,
we just didn't work out and that's fine.
But I remember just sitting there and I was just like,
I cannot stop doing this.
Was He the nightmare where you uh,
we'll talk about off the air.
It was definitely,
it's definitely not me.
I don't want to say what it was because I wasn't listening to happens to know
when we'll be like,
I know,
but it was right,
right.
Well,
I will share with you a story if you want to hear these please,
because this is really everything.
And I shared this for the first time in Tampa this weekend and I hadn't told the
to scoot on up to the microphone,
let us know.
Um,
I,
this is just a crazy night wearing the headphones.
That's why I'm letting people know,
like you,
when you move away,
left into the right of these things,
it changes the volume.
Do you think it really matters if you put it left or right?
No,
that doesn't matter.
But if we look at for blanche that was looking for the volume,
it's up here.
Oh,
that's fine.
Next to this assault.
That is a salt rock.
Yeah.
People like were hippies.
Here we have,
um,
look,
I have a lava lamps.
Salt rocks.
Yeah.
Jimi Hendrix.
I couldn't eat looking at the Predator thing.
I had a sandwich or won't be able to look at that and eat.
It grosses me out.
It's just a mask.
Halloween costumes grossed me out like the smell of latex and like that's
actually hard.
That's like a,
a model that was made by special effects guy.
It was looking at it cause he's so scary.
But like that thing couldn't eat you.
Uh,
you sure it could look a small mouth,
it would rip you apart.
Small mouth.
Yeah.
But it would chew chunks of you.
Let's,
and those other things act as teeth to just pull some meat off.
Yeah.
But it depends on how it can articulate and just trying to make them human.
I think he would appreciate that.
Okay.
So here's my story.
I hear please.
We were talking about relationship the beginning.
So I went through a breakup like a month and a half ago,
maybe two months ago.
I feel like you'll have you of all people will appreciate this story and I'll
give you the abridged version.
Um,
give me the juicy details.
So basically I met this guy a year,
two years,
not this thanksgiving,
the last one on the plane.
And we hit it off and he told me his name and he said he went to Yale and he
worked in,
we'll say,
well he worked in finances,
we'll just leave it at that.
And so I knew him for a year,
never wanted to date him.
And eventually we dated,
we dated for for three months and during the time we were dating,
um,
before we'd started dating,
he told me he bought a house and I never wanted to see the house because I
whatever,
it wasn't dating him,
I didn't care.
So we start dating and the whole time we're dating,
things start getting weird.
Like we get along perfectly.
But there are certain aspects of his personal life that are like not checking
out.
Like I told my mom,
I was like,
Oh hey,
this is his name and this is where he works.
So she googled him because that's what moms do,
right.
And his work bio says that he graduated from uh,
from a different college,
not he's anyone to Yale,
right.
Is that he'd graduates around.
So I call him,
I'm like,
why does it say that?
He's like,
Oh my God,
they've cut and pasted the wrong bio.
It's a mess up.
My company's a mess.
I'm like okay,
I get wrong buyers all the time.
Like I totally get it.
And I was like,
I want to send you a present,
what's your address?
And he's like,
oh just send it to my work.
And I was like,
no,
I want to send it to your house.
So he gives me this address.
So I sent him a gift and he gets it.
And then one day I'm out with my friend Laura and we're at lunch and we start to
build a case about why we think this guy is a liar as a joke at first cause
nothing's checking out.
So Laura's like,
let's drive by his house.
And I remember what the house looked like from the picture he'd sent me,
cause like six months before we were dating,
he was like,
check out this house that I bought.
So I go to the house and it's not a house,
it's an apartment.
And Laura goes up to the door and she's like looking in and all of a sudden the
girl opens the door and I'm just,
I'm just,
I was paralyzed and the girl looks at me,
she goes,
she was like,
hi,
can I help you guys?
And we're like,
oh,
we're just looking for the guy we're looking for.
And she was like,
Oh,
you're a [inaudible].
And I was like,
how the fuck do you know who I am?
And she was like,
Oh,
I'm his roommate.
And I was like,
okay,
well that's like,
I'm just not a cheating thing.
But I was like,
so I call him and I'm like,
why do you have a roommate?
And he goes,
well,
um,
my mom is sick and she moved to La and she lives at my house.
And I,
I,
she lives there and I live with my friend.
To give my mom privacy and I was like,
all right,
well that's weird,
but like I still want to know where you live.
Oh
God,
this guy should just change his number and run away from you.
Okay,
got it.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So I was like,
all right,
so I let it go and when we're together,
everything's great.
Like perfect.
You're not thinking about it at all.
I,
well that part I was like,
okay,
his mom has cancer.
That's what he told me.
And he's like,
she's wants privacy.
So I'm like,
okay.
And I fell in love with him in the first place because he told me she had cancer
and I got,
I wanted to take care of him and like that really like tugged on my
heartstrings.
So I was like,
okay.
I met them on once and every single time after I met her once,
like the first week we started dating and every time after that I'd be like,
let me take,
if you're at work,
I'm like,
I've got free time.
Let me take your mom to lunch.
Let me take your mom to the movies.
Can we go to like anything,
right.
Could never make it happen.
Let's go to brunch with your mom.
Let me do something.
Let me take her somewhere.
No.
When you met the mom,
did her illness ever come up in conversation?
No,
because I thought that would be tactless for me to be like,
how's your cancer?
Well,
I mean if she brought it up,
never brought her up,
right?
No,
nothing.
They came with me to the craft store.
I had to buy stuff for Christmas party.
Um,
we didn't say much,
but I never,
so weeks are going by and I'm like,
I just want to hang out.
Like if you love me.
And he always talked about getting married,
stuff like that.
I'm like,
I should probably meet this woman more than once.
So he gives me,
so I go to that.
So it's not,
so I call him and he's like,
uh,
my mom is living alone.
I intend to give her privacy.
And I was like,
okay,
that's fine,
but you need to tell me where you live.
Well,
you gave me that and I was like,
why are you being weird?
You gave me the address like six months ago before we were dating and he was
like,
um,
I,
uh,
he gives you a guy.
He's like,
I just,
I,
my mom's asked for privacy.
I'm just trying to give that to her.
He kept saying that.
So I'm like,
all right.
So finally,
eventually he goes,
here's the address and he gives me,
this address is five to five Kilkia.
So I'm like,
all right,
that's not the real addresses it,
so I have this address.
I'm like,
okay.
Thinking,
wow,
that took a lot for you to give that to me,
right?
Like this is clearly an issue and everyone's got their boundaries.
Everyone's got their baggage.
And I was trying to be respectful of that.
Couple of weeks go by,
my mom calls the Yale's registered,
he'll registrar's office because it's such a out no record of this guy ever
graduating.
Oh,
your mom's awesome as what everybody says.
So I call him and I'm like,
and I'm trying to be cool about it because again,
like this is someone that I love and we've traveled together and you don't want
to push it.
And he's like,
I don't know.
I was only on campus for this amount of time.
Did [inaudible] he'd already invited me to go to England with him for a skull
and bones reunion,
like a whole thing and wait,
it got canceled because his mom had cancer.
So like I'm like letting all this go.
So he goes out of town,
I go to five to five Kilkia it doesn't exist.
Oh No.
I call him and I'm like,
what are you fucking doing?
And he goes and he launching the story goes when I lived in the city he lived in
before he goes,
I had this crazy ex girlfriend,
everyone's got a crazy ex.
He was like,
and basically she wreak havoc on my life and my personal life with my family and
I'm just very protective of that.
And my mom's sick and I'm just trying to like keep her out of that.
So I was like,
okay.
I was like,
you need to give me your address.
This is the last time I'm going to ask you for this.
And I'm trying not to like push him.
So he comes over,
he gives me the address,
his mom's number and his email.
He's like,
I'm an open book,
whatever you want to know.
So I took that as a sign of like,
wow,
that was really hard for you.
Gail registrar comes back,
no record of him.
Uh,
none of my friends that went to Yale know who he is and every time I ask him
anything,
like the answer is super simple.
Like if I asked you where you live,
you just tell me to just roll off your tongue.
And that's everything was so I go to that house,
like I let a couple of weeks go by,
my birthday happens,
we had Christmas,
my birthday,
and it's a day before I'm leaving for San Antonio to go play this comedy club.
And I go to his house with my friend and it's not his house,
it's like some other woman lives.
They're like an old woman lives there.
It's not as mom's house.
And he sees like my mom,
he's like,
my mom bought the house from me to keep my cash liquid.
The title's not in her name.
I call him.
And I was like,
I'm walking out of your life because you're lying about something.
And it all came crashing down at 7:00 AM he texts me,
he goes,
I never went to Yale.
I never bought a house.
I've been lying to you for over a year.
And so it was just one of those.
And then so you start going back and then you start wondering if you're crazy
and then you're like,
does your mom even if cancer did you,
are you really in this moment cancer?
I'm going to say she does,
but I think it's really weird that I met her once and then like I was like,
what's the name of the doctor at the hospital where she is?
He's like,
I don't know,
like very like wouldn't give any information.
This is,
and so yesterday I wrote an email,
I don't know why I'm sharing all of this,
but this is very funny to me.
I wrote everybody,
when you break up with someone,
depending on how tactful you are,
you hold back on what you want to say.
Like we all say,
look or you're an asshole.
I hate you.
But like then there's like the dark shit that you don't write and I wrote an
email that I almost,
I won't do it,
but I almost want to post online as like a template for any girl that ever wants
to like enrage her next boyfriend.
And I just lost my shit and it felt so good.
Like fuck.
Having tact.
Like it just was the best thing ever.
Well it sounds like you gave him every possible every possible scenario for him
to be truthful.
Like you gave him every possible like well maybe he's this and maybe it's that
you gave a lot of leeway.
So much so and then every day I'd be like,
if you're lying,
please just tell me.
Or just tell anyone,
look me in the eye and be like,
I'm not lying.
Which makes me think if we ever got married,
we would go on a boat and he would kill me.
But the whole never know.
Right.
You never tell that shit happens.
You find out he's got a life insurance policy on you and I accidentally signed
it.
Did you find out where he worked?
Did he actually have the job that he had?
He had left the company and all of these things are weird.
Like he left the company and like a weird way and he started his own so that
like I just,
it's at some point it's not up to you to piece together what's real and what
isn't.
I told this story on the radio in Tampa and when I got off the air,
all of these people had sent me tweets with Yale
and somebody sent me a picture of someone running the Boston marathon in a
yellow shirt and they're like,
is your ex boyfriend running the Boston marathon?
Oh that poor bastard.
I'm glad you don't say his name publicly shame him because the poor fuck is
already a mess.
I told him he's fucking lucky.
I'm like,
you're I think on that show I did,
but I didn't.
I've never say the last name.
Well he is lucky you could make them a part of your act with his actual name.
It's so be a killer bit.
If I could think of unrelatable the whole like the exact amount of lying and
cheating thing saying I thought man you meant like as a bit right.
I think it's very relatable.
I think I will get around to it.
I think eventually it'll stop.
I'll stop being,
cause I'm not sad anymore,
but my email pretty much included cause like obviously,
you know if you break up with someone you don't want to hear about people
they're sleeping with.
Right.
He got upset because I posted a picture when I was in Saint Martin of
[inaudible] topless beach with two friends in front of me.
So you can't see anything.
And he was like,
I felt that you posted that picture and it was directed at me,
which it wasn't like I posted like a hot picture.
And so I just unleashed on this email and I was like,
it's none of your fucking business.
What I do.
And by the way,
when I was in Saint Martin,
I hooked up with a guy when he went down on me for 20 minutes and it was fucking
awesome.
I will never talk to you.
Whoa.
That's dark.
It felt so good.
Oh,
the act makes you cringe.
But the idea of not around.
No,
no,
no.
The act doesn't make me cringe at all.
Were you writing that email and say,
look,
I'm a guy and he went down.
He ate my pleasure.
I did not say that.
I didn't say anything.
Same thing you said it.
Here's the question though.
At what point are you as a human being allowed to just unleash and be like,
that's it?
Well,
yes.
Honestly,
I don't think that guy's worth your effort,
you know,
making more tension with him.
I mean that,
that's a crazy person.
That guy's fabricating and existence.
He fabricated his education.
He fabric.
He may have fabricated his mother being sick.
He fabricated where he lived twice or three times.
Three times.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's probably pathological.
You know,
there are people that just can't stop lying.
I've seen it before when,
um,
you're living in Hollywood,
you know,
if you live around here,
you,
you'll meet people that are,
you know,
fake it til you make it type people that will tell you stories that just don't
add up.
And in the old days you used to just have to kind of accept people at those
stories.
But now your mom can just Google them and find out anything
she got on it.
Ah,
you're on and got on it.
Wow.
Your mom's awesome.
Good for her.
Well,
let me ask you this,
cause this is,
um,
this is the difference between a man and a woman because you could tell me that
you went to pierce college or you went to a high school and you dropped out when
you were 16.
And if you're,
you and I like you,
I don't care at all.
It doesn't mean anything to me.
I don't care if you're a nurse.
I don't care if you're a doctor.
I don't care if you're a brain surgeon or a girl who works in a clothing store.
Right.
It doesn't matter to me who would care if I do not care,
do not care if
someone's fun and nice to be around.
I do not care.
I really don't.
I never have.
I never will.
Um,
obviously it's,
it's,
there's a difference between a man and a woman,
like women desire men to be successful.
Sure.
And that's a whole,
that's an evolution thing and that's a protective thing.
And that's,
I get that.
Obviously I don't want to date like a homeless person.
Right.
What killed nor does,
nor do I.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't want someone who can't feed themselves does,
you know,
it's about quality.
What kills me is that those things genuinely don't matter.
And he chose to judge me ahead of time,
or maybe he's got a chemical imbalance from the day I met him on the plane.
I went to Yale.
Nothing wrong with lying to a stranger or a pretty girl on a plane.
I don't care where there is something wrong with Kenya.
There's no,
there's no ramifications for lying to a stranger if you never see them again.
Right,
right.
Okay.
Um,
that doesn't bother me.
I don't care if you own a house so it irks it.
It's a shame because you lied about two things.
Let's say it's just too and you ruined a perfectly good relationship.
If it's just those two things in your insecure.
I didn't go to Harvard.
I'm not a road scholar.
I don't care if you went to Yale,
how long did you guys date for him?
I knew him for over a year and we dated for about three months.
And what was it about his personality that was attractive to you?
Does a whizzer a unique thing you could define?
Truthfully,
I mean as friends he was very smart.
I really,
for me intelligence is a huge thing and very in a little like funniest,
snobby way,
like a little con and I kind of liked that and he's very smart,
very,
very smart,
a little Dorky,
very smart.
But when he,
when we were friends and when he called me and was like,
we can't go on this trip to the skull and bones thing because my mom has cancer.
I got a chance.
This is going to be weird.
I don't know if,
I think only women will relate to this for the whole time we knew each other.
He put me on this pedestal,
always asking,
can you please,
can we please date?
Can I have the kids?
Will you be my girlfriend?
And I were like,
we would hang out.
And I was like,
stop it.
Like I'm not into this.
So no one wants to be on a pedestal because there's nothing for you to do.
His mom had cancer.
I was like,
I can take care of you.
And now like you've been nothing but sweet to me.
Now let me take care of you.
And in getting to take care of him,
I started to like him cause I had like an active role.
It's so crazy.
Um Wow.
That's so crazy.
But yeah,
those things didn't matter.
So is that like the maternal instincts that you have is like the,
the taking care of instincts,
you know,
because some women have those instincts sort of built in those?
I think so.
But I think it was also just,
there was nothing for me to do to have an active role in our relationship as
friends.
Like he had a lot of money and a lot of time and he could do nice things like he
would,
did he really have a lot of money because they have a lot of money.
Well how's that possible?
He has a fucking roommate.
So the roommate,
if,
if the answer was he goes,
I have my lease was up in Santa Monica.
I was going to buy a house.
But then I decided I thought it was going to move.
He goes again.
Then you and I started dating.
I didn't want to move.
I moved in with a friend to help her pay her rent cause he's never home and he's
like,
so I just leave my stuff there but how can you even trust that I couldn't,
he did send me a picture of his bank account to like why he was a human being.
Come on,
I didn't ask for it.
He sent you the numbers in his bag.
He sent me like a screen grab of it.
This motherfucker doctored his bank account,
Photoshop the shit out of his bank account.
I,
you know,
I saw the way he lived in the way he,
I mean I do think the money thing is real.
We did,
maybe it may,
I may or may not have done a background check.
So I definitely know when he came from.
Um,
but the answer your question to the House and the,
the college and like,
he lied about weird things.
What is that?
That's a weird thing,
man.
That's saying you went to Yale,
like the,
you know,
Harvard,
Yale,
Ivy League.
Like,
that's like,
Ooh,
I don't,
and then he would sit in,
my cousin went to Yale and they would have a conversation and he would talk
about it.
What?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Poor bet you're ripping paper over there for you.
Right.
And she's going crazy.
It's just so like the Tucker,
no,
not even that.
Every time
go back and I'm like,
what,
what clues did I miss?
What am I,
and like,
what,
what am I realizing now?
Like I'm trying to like put the dot,
like connect the dots.
The day I met him,
I went on Twitter and I followed him and his Twitter handle an had a Yale
reference in it.
And I asked him like when we broke up,
I was like,
even your Twitter was about Yale.
And he was like,
I made up my Twitter account the day I met you.
Whoa.
Just because he met you and he wanted,
oh my God,
he didn't.
Maybe he lied.
Maybe he changed the name.
Uh Wow.
What a psycho.
And every time I tell the story,
like I think about different things that I missed.
So Jesus Christ,
the good news is when something that weird happens to you,
there's no lesson to be learned.
It's not like,
oh,
I thought he was cheating.
Like that's a normal thing.
Like this is not something I'll take into another relationship.
Like I'm not,
you kind of do because you guys do lie about their past to become more
impressive to a girl.
You know?
I mean it is really,
it's super common,
right?
And now you'll sort of recognize those sort of bullshit signs maybe quicker.
Well,
maybe it's like when a guy throws that out there,
like makes a big deal out of it.
Like maybe that's when you look.
Maybe,
maybe.
I mean some people like it wasn't really online.
Some people take pride in not really being online a lot that,
I mean the Internet helps.
Like and when,
if you can,
I went on a date last night and you could Google the guy and everything about
him is there
and you're like,
me and this guy had no friends in common.
Like the email I wrote him was so,
I guess so pointed it to me.
I'll send it,
I'll show it to you right after this.
I went online and he deleted his Twitter account.
Like,
I think I made this motherfucker leave cyberspace.
Oh,
it's bad.
Well you should.
I mean that's for him.
It's gotta be some people just do that over and over and over again though.
My friend Eddie met this guy and this guy,
um,
he was working on,
he wanted to put him in some project.
He was doing some television and
he claimed that he had these studios and he was working with all these networks
and this and that.
But where we found out that he was full of Shit,
I thought he was full of Shit right away.
I told Eddie,
Alec,
I don't like the way this guy talks.
He named jobs too much.
I go,
I think he's a bullshitter.
I think there's,
there's a certain thing that people do when they bullshit when they talk about
like,
I've got a project going on with Steven Spielberg and this,
there's just no fucking way Tom Cruise is passing on the project.
We want to bring it to you.
Like,
you know,
you know what I mean?
It's like one of those things.
Sure.
So the,
I,
you know,
I was peripheral,
I wasn't,
you know,
interacting with sky,
but Eddie was interacting with this guy.
I'm like any of that guy's a bullshitter.
He smells,
I go,
I just,
he just smells.
So then the guy starts taking Jujitsu class.
Okay.
I mean zero experience in Jujitsu and then calls Eddie after doing Jujitsu for
like,
I dunno like a day,
maybe two days.
And it's talking about catching people and triangles and all these different
submissions that he pulled off,
which is never going to happen.
Like it's just not going to happen unless,
unless you're doing it with someone who is absolutely physically competent.
When you,
when you first start out,
you don't know what you're doing,
you don't learn that day one.
We'll also,
he's not a stud.
The guy wasn't like,
there's certain guys like it,
you can take a guy,
he's like a pro basketball player who's just a fucking athlete and maybe he
loves MMA and maybe he's never taken a Jujitsu classes life,
but he's seen a few fights and if he recognizes the position that you teach it
to him,
he could maybe pull it off on someone who sucks.
Yeah,
but it's an advanced move,
like setting up a triangle,
finishing it.
It's an advanced move.
And this guy was like,
I got three triangles today and practice and to armbars when we were like,
wait,
what?
And I go,
I told you he's a bullshitter.
And then he go,
well,
he did actually go to class.
He did not ever tap anyone ever.
He is physically in competent.
Like if you,
if you see him,
you look at his body,
it's like this guy is lucky if he can brush his teeth like this isn't a fucking
athlete at all.
I mean he was just like,
it was a gumby.
He was a guy who essentially had never worked out his whole life and then all of
a sudden he's claiming he's tapping people out in Jujitsu.
But that was just confirmation.
Then ed,
he looked into his,
his whole situation and found out the guy was just a total complete liar.
Broke it down with them over the phone.
There's another one I've got is a guy,
he,
his name,
his real name was Ralph and he was telling us that his name was Rafael Tori.
And,
um,
he was saying that he was a black belt in Jujitsu as friends or like how did
you,
well this guy I'm telling us,
he was his friend and he was a journalist for a mixed martial arts magazine,
an online magazine.
And so he would go to these events and uh,
and he would do,
Eddie was a,
one of the commentators for the king of the cage,
which is a smaller mixed martial arts,
a organization familiar with King and again and uh,
anyway,
Rafael Tory actually had a fake fight.
I mean he,
he said that he was a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
He was not at all.
Eddie rolled with them and Eddie is a black belt and at the time I don't think
was a black,
but I think Eddie was a brown belt and he just smashed him,
just tapped him left and right.
And he was like confused.
He was like,
well maybe they,
maybe it wasn't really trying or like I don't get it cause he was a bigger guy
too.
It was like way too easy for Eddie to tap them.
So Eddie there,
there was a few like red flags that popped up there.
Anyway,
long story short,
the guy never digits before it,
it was a complete fake would disappear and here's a good one.
Went away.
Okay.
It told his friend to drop him off,
like pulled up to this a wooded area,
told his friend to drop him off.
He had a duffle bag with them filled with some shit,
right?
He says,
uh,
dropped me off here.
I'm going to fight in this no rules karate tournament out in the woods and then
I'll be back in two days.
Okay.
So his friend comes back in two days and now he doesn't have the duffle bag in.
My buddy has a trophy that's the same size as the fucking duffle bag one.
This no rules karate tournament.
I mean,
and everybody's like,
wait,
what the fuck?
Okay,
so the guy completely made up is martial arts background completely made up.
He also went to Thailand for a fight and got a guy in a twister.
Twister is a very complex move that involves not just getting on top of Oh God,
but getting on top of guy inside control,
lacing one leg with your two legs rolling on your shoulders.
So you go behind him,
take his back,
you wrap his arm around your head,
grab his head and Torque his spine.
It's an incredibly complex maneuver.
This guy just learned it and he started pulling it off on people in,
in a fucking no holds barred fight.
So there was all these things.
So Eddie,
Eddie cuts the guy off and he's like,
listen man,
you're bullshit artists.
I know you're full of shit.
You're not a fucking black belt.
You're not fighting in these fucking fights.
He just wanted to be near it.
Yeah,
he goes,
I know that your fight.
But Eddie had been friends with this guy for months and months and months,
just slowly piled on the bullshit.
You know,
just not trying to investigate a guy,
just thinking he's a cool guy.
He was already in the mix before Eddie got there.
He was already deepen with these mixed martial arts guy.
So he just assumed that a guy's legit.
Turns out as the time goes on,
he murdered a guy,
murdered a guy who was married to a girl that he was fucking,
he got close to the guy and I guess he had like some sort of karate school that
he was teaching that with his fake fake martial arts.
And,
uh,
got the guy to come to his school,
strangled him,
killed him,
and then was driving the guy's car,
Rau witnesses,
saw him drive the guy's car around and,
um,
had a gun that he gave to my friend Gerald and told Gerald to hide it.
And then Gerald,
you know,
calls me up and tells me the whole situation.
And I was like,
what?
What the fuck happened?
The Guy,
what did he kills him?
And then Gerald goes to the cops.
Okay.
And then the cops called me because Gerald had apparently been,
um,
they had wiretapped him while all this was going down because they suspected
that this guy,
Raphael,
his real name was Ralph,
wasn't resilient of the,
that's the worst part of the line.
You said he was Brazilian and he wasn't Brazilian,
he'd be,
he just faked his ethnicity,
faked his martial arts background,
and now he's in jail for life.
I mean,
he's a,
he's in jail for murder and a lot of twisters in jail.
That's what you're saying now,
but I mean,
is that not,
that's the ultimate bullshit.
Ours fake black belt,
fake ethnicity,
fake name.
The trophy thing is fucking amazing.
It's hilarious.
Story is so crazy.
It makes you sound crazy when you're telling me
yes,
it does.
Well,
you can look the guy up.
Google the guy,
Rafael,
Tori,
I mean it's uh,
it's an incredible story that gets passed back and forth through,
uh,
the mixed martial arts world.
But the point is that before the Internet,
I mean this was,
there was websites back then and there was martial arts websites.
It was like 2000,
I want to say like two or three or something like that.
But you couldn't like Google the guy you could like find out the guy's
background.
Right,
right,
right.
Like if you Google Eliza slutching anger that I said,
I say it right.
There is no such objection.
The metal singer hi saying yet assessing right now.
How do you say it's it?
Right?
Well I've been saying slushing juror forever.
[inaudible] Shlesinger slashing Gersh less singer Schlesinger.
I'll never say it wrong again.
Eliza.
Slash.
Anger.
You're going to say it wrong every time.
Every time.
I'm not one,
it will be wrong just as it's been in the past.
And that was going to call you Eliza cause that's your Twitter handle.
That's who you are to me.
But if I Google you,
I find out about last comic standing.
I see pictures of you topless on the beach with two guys holding their arms over
your titties.
I see a lot of things.
I've seen it.
It's on my message board.
Yeah,
this is Raphael Tori,
the guy on the left hand side with the guy on the right hand side with the
glasses is Tito motherfucking Ortiz.
Former world champion of the UFC.
So this guy,
this guy,
but this guy got in deep,
that guy on the left,
not the guy without the red in his jacket.
The guy on,
it's his left,
right.
You are right.
This is so complicated.
Flyer is the one,
yeah,
the guy in the right hand side of the photograph.
The guy with the mustache.
Yes.
Thank you.
There we go.
The guy without the glasses.
That's Rafael Torres.
He's in jail for murder and he's a fake black belt and he's uh,
you know everything about his fake,
his names fake.
And that guy like got deep,
deep,
deep in the martial arts world as a fraud.
That's so crazy.
Fascinating.
Also,
I mean,
I guess you,
and you want to ask Kevin as I asked the ex boyfriend,
I was like,
what was your end game here buddy?
Did you have a conversation with him after this or was it just email and that's
it.
Did you talk,
talk?
He texted any,
I mean,
he apologize.
This wasn't like poof.
I'm gone.
Like there's a lot of,
you know.
But did you think about like keeping a Morag?
Could it?
No way I couldn't because like you have to take yourself,
I mean,
I even,
I knew this,
you have to take yourself out of like you,
your hurt and your heart's broken.
You're allowed to let that heal.
But getting back with someone like that is not,
first of all,
I lose respect from my all my friends and family and it also like you can't
trust that person.
The end game for you is that you'd be dating someone you couldn't trust however.
Um,
but I as you know,
and he just,
and never,
that's the other thing.
And I said in the email,
I was like,
I'm,
I don't have all the answers from him.
I said,
I'm willing to trade my lack of closure for the privilege of never having to
talk to you again.
So I will write my own closure.
I'll draw my own conclusions.
I won't defend you to anyone.
And he went down on me for 20 minutes
outside,
outside to danger pussy.
That's so crazy that,
that,
that the lack of closure thing is a big thing.
Right.
Cause you'll stay up late,
try to figure it out.
Do you like find yourself like during the day,
like just driving around and trying to piece it
together?
Yeah.
Where did,
I was sitting on the plane yesterday.
And like it,
especially when you just go through a breakup,
like you're,
you know,
you think about that person,
whatever.
And the hard thing is not,
I'm past that phase.
There's no I,
the number's blocked.
Like I can't call him or anything.
But yeah,
you sit there and you go back over things and then I start like,
here's a weird piece of the puzzle if you want to know what I was thinking.
Um,
when before we were dating,
he invited me to go to England for the skull and bones thing and obviously not
in skull and bones.
You didn't go to Yale.
And even after this all happened,
he goes,
well,
my dad was in skull and bones and I'm like,
your dad went to Yale Grad school,
what's his name?
What's Your Dad's name?
Dad's dead in real life.
That's what I mean that for.
But uh,
he invited me to go to England,
so I was going to go separate rooms and I went out to dinner with a friend who
has a body that I really liked.
So I took a picture of my drink and in the background was my friend's body.
He's like a big guy,
so the point of the picture was to be like,
look at this hot thing I'm having a drink with not so much to be like,
look at the drink.
I think he saw that picture because I don't remember if it was before or after,
but that was the night he called me and said,
we can't go to England.
My mom has cancer.
I think he saw that picture on Instagram and he was like,
I got to do something to shake this up if the,
if the mom doesn't have cancer.
It's odd that that was the night of all nights.
So you were friends only up until that point.
Yeah.
Let me tell you something.
There's friends and there's friends with an agenda and you and I are friends.
We will never have sex.
I'll tell you that right now.
I'm married,
we're friends.
I'm not going to let it happen.
Eliza stopped with those eyes,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like we're legitimate friends.
Amy Schumer's another one.
She's my legitimate friends and I,
you know,
I think it's very important to like have men and women like that,
that are friends like that.
There's like a line that will never be crossed.
It's like you can't,
but there's guys who are really never your fucking friend.
Never,
ever,
ever.
It's done.
The whole thing was a lie from the beginning.
I knew that like I'm not dumb and he had said that to me.
He's like,
goes over your friend but you,
he was someone that I,
we had,
we hung out and we had a really nice like relationship his friends and
definitely I would get drunk once in a while and I'd be like,
let's make out.
Like that's like a girl thing.
But it was never what,
hold on.
You would get drunk and say let's make out like I would kiss him and like go
inside a big deal.
What?
Kiss him like tongue and everything.
The whole deal.
Like a drunk,
make out kiss fully clothed and then like go inside.
Whoa.
That's so girl.
It's so gross.
So crazy.
I also said,
I would say to him,
I'm like,
look at any point,
and I'm very upfront on us.
I'd say at any point we can stop hanging out.
I go,
I'm never going to date you.
You need to know that.
And He,
meanwhile,
you dated him eventually,
but,
but my point is,
the whole time we were dating,
I was honest.
I was like,
I have no intention of dating you.
Yeah,
but you kissed him ton.
You can walk away.
I didn't chain him to the wall and I was like,
I'm going to date other guys.
I'm going to have other guys be my boy.
Like not when I was kissing him,
but I was like,
I'm probably never going to date you.
Right.
And he hung around.
Well,
I,
and I understand that.
I mean,
well,
he's definitely a silly man for hanging around,
but not because he eventually got to fuck you.
So he wins,
I guess.
I don't think really.
Oh,
neat.
Well,
listen again,
because you're a girl.
Listen,
you kissed him.
You,
you tongued him.
And he eventually got in there.
But you're telling me that every girl you've brought prior to being married,
every girl you ever like drunk made out with that meant something to you?
No,
no,
no.
But I think there's a difference between you saying to someone,
look,
first of all,
I'm a man.
When a man drunkenly makes out with a girl,
he absolutely wants to fuck her.
If a girl drunkenly makes out with a guy,
she can do it just to be silly,
I guess.
And then just shut the door and go in.
Yeah.
Guys don't ever do that.
That's okay.
If a guide drunkenly makes out with a girl,
it's almost always because he eventually,
ultimately wants to have sex with her.
But,
but,
um,
but that's,
that's how guys are and that's not how girls are.
And I think all any girl would relate to that.
Like you get,
you know,
or you're just,
I mean,
you're drunk and you want to,
sometimes you just want to make out with someone.
And that's the God's honest truth.
Like we all get horny and I don't feel like having that goes x.
Here's my point though.
No matter what relationship you're conducting,
even like even if you feel I'm throwing mixed signals,
you at any point are allowed to walk away.
At no point was I like,
I love you.
Please stay.
It was me being like,
I'm going to make out with you.
Maybe I'll take my shirt off.
I'm not going to date you.
Maybe I'll go take my shirt off.
But this one,
the whole time they will.
I started from day one so it isn't as if like they came into play later,
like the whole time and then I think what he was like,
what happened is I lied and I know what to do.
He's like,
I didn't think we would date.
You always told us and told me we wouldn't.
And then we did.
He's like,
I didn't know what to do.
And I'm like,
hold on,
it's on you.
Well that's definitely on him and the lies are unacceptable.
I just,
all I'm trying to do is as your friend breakdown though the mindset and try to
figure out like how someone says,
I will tongue you and kiss you and take my shirt off.
But we're never going to have sex for a guy that's like,
if we're getting that close,
if your tits are coming out and my tongue's in your mouth.
Okay.
Jets.
I was joking about the shirt thing.
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
I don't think,
I think everybody's been there.
Words like a drunk make out to the end of the night and you're just like,
whatever.
I feel like making out.
And so you do like,
you like I know this person and this is fine and they're like,
I ever totally support
your,
your right to make out with people and you're drunk and have like a very
specific boundary where it's not going to go any further than this.
We're never going to date and not,
but if you want to make out,
I'll make out with you right now.
But that's it.
And then that's it.
That's your prerogative.
100% this on your show.
We did.
I mean like a long time ago where I will,
if I'm like,
let's say I'm seeing someone,
and let's say it's like the second date or something,
I will straight up say to a guy,
I'm not gonna Sleep with you just yet.
Like I don't,
I'm not going to do that.
But if you wanna go upstairs,
we can make out among your wiener,
I'll take my shirt off.
That is a treat for you.
Great.
Tomorrow you'll buy me breakfast.
And no one has ever said no.
When you give men certain boundaries of parameters ahead of time,
and then I'm giving you the option to say I'm good,
or I'm tired,
or I think I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go home.
Whatever you want.
That way you're not disappointed.
No one's ever pushed it.
No one's ever tried to get me to do more than wanting to do.
And no one's ever said no.
Well,
you're a very strong personality.
You know?
And if you say that,
uh,
guys,
I'm not saying every guy would respect it,
but most guys who go,
she's not fucking around.
Like,
this is what she wants.
And it's better than nothing for a lot of guys that like,
wow,
it's better than nothing.
Yeah,
we'll go make out and squeeze them titties date.
Yeah.
That's great.
And then eventually we'll fuck.
So it's like,
yeah,
yeah.
Well there's nothing wrong with that because also we're talking to,
if I was a girl also it would be really difficult for me,
I assume to just trust a man.
Like physically,
like there's the,
the physical thing.
Like,
look,
you had this guy,
you knew him for a fucking year,
you dated him for three months and he turned out to be a complete total
bullshit.
Ours.
What if it was,
you knew him for a year,
you date him for three months and he turned out to be a fucking psychopath and
you didn't know the whole time you were date.
Well it sort of right,
but I mean,
what if it's the whole time you were dating,
he was raping girls while you weren't around.
I mean,
that's just as possible as him faking Yale.
He could have been a serial rapist or house right now with a gun.
Like he could be a total fucking,
yeah.
Yeah.
Did he have a key?
I don't at any point in time
he did like from the only thing that,
because we'd known each other for a year.
So when you know someone for a year and then date,
it's a little,
you could take it a little bit faster because it isn't like you just started
dating.
I've nowhere but like a month.
And he's like,
I'd love to move in.
Like what can we move in together?
And I've definitely dated guys that like to go fast and you've got to like pump
the brakes.
And now I'm like,
okay,
I'm the one computer.
Great Guy.
You're the Guy Alive.
I always go along with it too.
Yeah,
I'm on it.
Cause I'm like,
yeah,
let's be fucking intense.
Let's,
let's sit in Nancy this into the ground.
Yeah.
But if you really enjoy life and you really enjoy the person fucking why not who
the shit.
But I for this one
color,
I was like relaxed with the,
with the moving in thing.
Right.
Um,
and now and now it's even where I'm like,
so what,
so what was your plan like?
You were going to reveal all this and then you'd be living with me.
God,
could you imagine if you were living with this fucking guy and all that stuff
came out?
Uh,
it would have been,
I mean,
I would have had paid my mortgage from afar.
Yeah.
What would you do?
Jesus Christ physical thing.
I always kind of like test.
If I'm dating someone,
like I'll be like,
let's,
I'm going to try to get past you and see if you can stop me.
Are you serious?
I always just try to see physically
where we are.
I definitely almost beat a boyfriend in a restaurant,
an arm wrestling match one time.
Yeah.
Not everybody works out,
but not everybody's angry.
But I definitely was in a workout and I'm angry or you're trying to say,
and I did not add,
isn't comparative.
Uh,
but the physical thing,
I definitely pretty works on that.
Everybody's angry for me.
I know saying,
I mean I was saying I'm,
I work out and I'm angry,
but I definitely have a male friend that I have made out with and one time we
were making out and I,
he's a giant person and I actually got scared just being under a body that big.
And I was like,
if your arms give out,
like I'm toast.
Like it's done for me.
Yeah,
you won't be able to breathe.
What if he has an aneurysm when he passed out on top of you and you suffocate?
That could happen.
Cause I sometimes I'll do that.
I'll be like laying on top of me.
I want to see if I can get you off of me.
You know what the key is?
You got to breathe through your stomach.
If a guy's on top of you,
this is what you do and they pass out on it,
you can still breathe,
but you have to breathe through your stomach.
The problem is,
well this is the thing.
Everybody wants to be like this.
You want to breathe like that.
You can agree with diaphragm.
You can,
yeah.
You can breathe from your diaphragm,
will you literally only move your stomach because it's doing anything for anyone
listening,
listening to Joe Rogan,
but you can,
you can breathe with your stomach where your,
your chest doesn't expand and contract and it's very important when someone's
compressing you and someone's on top of you and they're,
they're,
they're smashing you.
You have to learn how to stay calm.
If you're going to date someone,
learn how to breathe from your diaphragm.
Well,
when you're getting choked too,
it's a big one.
You have to learn how to relax and how to conserve your breath and how to
control your heart rate.
Breathing to my stomach,
like I feel like I can't take a big breath.
You can't.
That's the whole part of it.
You're going to have to deal.
No,
you won't.
You'll,
you'll be okay.
You just have to know which you have to do is you have to get comfortable with
the fact that you're not going to take a full breath.
I don't want to get comfortable.
Well,
you're going to have to get out from under this fucking big guy.
How big we're talking about 300 pounds is a big person.
Yep.
300 pounds on top of you and you're a little bit low.
Okay.
To 80 and you're,
you know what,
one 10 sure.
What do you weigh?
Okay,
forget it.
You're a a thin in shape woman who's about five four,
right?
Five five.
Okay.
So this big giant gorilla guy,
right.
Could conceivably kill me.
Yeah.
Anytime he wants you think about that and you're like,
oh,
this person.
So you really just never know.
Everyone's a ticking time bomb.
And I was like,
if you choose to snap right now,
well,
I also have friends that are,
there's a friend a,
and then there's friend a when he's drunk,
which I don't even know that guy.
Sure.
There's,
there's people that get drunk and their eyes glaze over and they're like a
totally different person.
They say shit to people that you would never see them say when they're sober.
They get aggressive,
they get Douchey,
they start fights and utilize that make you mad.
You're like us.
You don't get the luxury of alcohol.
You can't control yourself and act like a person so you shouldn't be able to
drink.
Well it's alcoholism is what it is and I've never understood alcoholism when I,
I'm sort of ignorant in that way that I always,
um,
what's the best way to say this?
Uh,
my own shortcomings.
I F I thought that it was a weakness that people had and it was just simply a
matter of character.
And I didn't believe in a alcoholism as a disease,
but I have personally seen people wear their personality.
So radically change is under the influence of alcohol that I,
there's no other way to attribute it to that.
Like almost like an allergic reaction.
Like they become a different person.
It's like they're,
their body is just not good with alcohol.
That alcohol,
and this is,
I'm actually asking,
it's not positing this just for funsies is it alcoholism?
If you know you're not drinking all the time and it's just when you have a drink
you at crazy.
Is that still alcoholism?
I think it is.
I think some people,
for whatever reason,
whether it's genetic and there are,
I think there's definitely a genetic mechanism to alcoholism as well.
And I don't know what it is.
I don't,
I'm,
I'm not totally educated on it,
but there's some people were alcoholism runs in the family.
I don't,
I'm like you,
I didn't grow up with any alcoholics.
I grew up in like a suburb where I think when you grow up somewhere like La,
la in particular it,
I was talking about this last night at dinner,
it sort of breathe,
it's this,
uh,
environment where everyone is recovery and it's part of the conversation in
general.
So you grow up very sensitive to those things and what alcohol is,
can do and what addicts behavior and mentality is.
I didn't grow up with any of that.
Right.
And I don't choose to be educated on it because I don't have to be part of that
world.
I'm not putting them down or anything,
but I'm not going to date anyone with an addict mentality.
I'm not surrounded by anyone with that.
It's not a,
it's not an education that I need.
Would you avoid someone who had been to rehab and would you avoid someone who
used to have an alcohol or a drug problem?
I like drinking.
Like I like to go out and have fun and I don't want to offend even there's
certain people that can drink and they're like,
I don't care if you drink that,
that can't drink and they don't care if you drink around them because it's such
a big social aspect.
It would depend on the person.
Um,
and it would also depend on what the eye,
it's not about judging them,
but it's are you the kind of person who has these triggers and it's going to be
an issue for the rest of your life or are you dealing with it but able to
function?
It really would just depend on the person.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean I have no problem with someone who gets her shit together and realizes
they had a problem and then pulls it out.
And again,
I think there really is some sort of a genetic component to alcoholism.
Well there is,
but I don't,
I think I get irritated because when you're younger like,
and when you're in your twenties and we all have those friends,
like we would have friends that would just do weird shit when they would get
drunk.
I'm very much the same person.
I'm very,
I'm,
when I'm drunk,
I'm just like a little bit looser,
but I'm not saying weird things.
I'm not starting fights.
I remember everything.
Um,
and when people can't act like humans when they get drunk,
I just choose to remove myself from that.
Yeah.
The aggressive drunks are the weirdest ones to me.
Like I'm the opposite.
When I'm drunk,
I'm everyone's friend over.
The last thing I want to do is get in a fight when I'm drunk.
I just never gonna work out.
You're never going to wake and be like,
oh wow.
I really rocked all those people.
And one I came out unscathed and drove home.
Well,
there are people that can,
when they're drunk,
don't
get confused.
If you,
you're thinking that,
oh,
this guy's drunk,
I can kick his ass now guys.
Especially the retard strength.
Yeah.
Well,
there's just some people that know how to fight and when they're drunk doesn't
really diminish that much.
Okay.
And they like it.
But I think for the most part,
people that get drunk and want to fight,
they're not skilled for every guy like that.
There's a guy like tank Abbott out there,
there's a rare duty could drink a fucking gallon of vodka and beat the shit out
of a whole room full of bad asses.
Right.
There's guys like that out there.
Probably date him next.
And Abbott please.
He's got a big giant beer belly and he's well UFC veteran.
Oh,
that sounds awful.
Uh,
he's awesome.
Tank Abbott sounds awesome.
He's awesome.
Yeah,
that's tank cabinet.
There he is.
Oh my God.
He's a bug.
An animal.
That Guy Gordon's fisherman,
but bloated.
He,
what I love about that guy is like he would fight anybody and you could call him
up a day before he'd be on a bar stool.
You can call him up and go tank.
Do you want to fight this weekend?
You'd be like,
fuck yeah,
tell me where to be would show off.
And he might not be in shape,
you know,
because he wasn't training because he was drinking.
But he would try to fucking win with every ounce of his being.
And if you went out on his shield,
he went out on his shield and you catch him that night at the bar and you better
not start talking shit to him about how he lost,
cause he'll fucking knock your teeth down.
Your throat on.
People are just,
cause motherfuckers enjoys it.
He legitimately enjoyed fighting.
It takes every type of people to make this crazy world go around.
There's people like that too.
What about can I hit in the face?
That's what I always want to know about.
Like I would ask Rhonda,
it'd be like,
aren't you afraid of getting hit in the face?
Well you can't be afraid of getting hit in the face if that's what you do for a
living.
But getting hit in the face is not fun.
No,
it's not good for you either.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I did that.
To me it would,
it's not so much.
No,
I don't.
I'm not a fight.
I'm not a physical fighter.
I might be a tough girl.
But like the idea of like either hitting someone in the face or getting hit in
the face,
I don't want to lose a tooth.
Well,
you're smart.
That's why some people don't have any idea what it's like to get hit in the
face.
And so they like,
think of it like very nonchalantly.
Well,
it's weird that you say that because I've had this conversation with,
it's mostly my Italian male friends,
but he ain't trying to say,
I don't know what road headquarters.
Italian one quarter Irish.
Okay,
well that explains a lot.
Just kidding.
Um,
but there is that thing,
that mentality where,
and I think because I hang out with enough men,
I'm able to identify this.
There's certain,
there's like a certain attitude by guys who have never been hit in the face
before.
And it's not always,
but there's a certain cockiness where like no one knows what fear is.
No one's ever instilled fear on them.
Right?
So they're assholes and you're like,
what do you need to do is go out and have someone beat the fuck out of you so
you can show a little bit of humility and not be such a dick all the time.
Some people need to get beaten up.
It's not for girls,
girls,
I need to get beaten up.
But some guys like just in the way that they address other men are the way that
they act.
And you're like,
you've never,
you've never been humiliated or taken down a peg ever.
You're totally right.
That's the word.
Well that's what I think martial arts are very important for men growing up.
Not because they need to get beat up just because they need to control their
ego.
And one of the best ways to control your ego is to put yourself into incredibly
difficult
situations,
tests your character,
and then you have confidence so you don't behave in that way in the first place.
I think a lot of the way guys behave that sort of delusional behavior.
It's almost a convinced themselves.
It's like this weird chest pub puffy thing and it comes out a lot of times when
they're drunk because they don't have confidence.
They don't have the real confidence that someone who's been tested and
understands their character and knows their limitations.
You know,
I think there's two schools of thought because what you just said was you were
saying how they have to convince themselves.
So there's almost,
there's like the way of the warrior,
which is the one you're talking about.
And then there's like the used car salesman where it's like,
Eh,
like ABC baby and I'm taking seminars and if I don't believe at first,
then who else will,
and it's almost like that like sort of unconscious delusional mentality where
like light it might like,
it's almost like if you lie to yourself,
then you can lie to others that works.
If you're on a plane,
you're trying to pick up a check and then get into a relationship with her for a
year as a friend and then three months while you're fucking her.
I mean just that can work.
Go bulldogs.
He just got to know how to sling it.
You know,
bullshit.
It does work on occasionally,
even with smart,
I mean that's what's the most impressive thing about his accomplishment.
You are,
you know,
you're one of my smartest friends.
You're smart,
you're very smart.
You're very quick.
And for a guy to trick you like that and a trick you over a long period of time
with a lot of,
you know,
a lot of questions along the way where you hit some bumps I guess.
But here's the other thing.
I mean I don't even know if the word is trick and I'll,
I mean I totally fell for it.
The shit out of you.
I feel like,
I guess it is tricky,
but it's also one that he's like,
why would I question that in my life?
No one's ever lied about where they went to school that I knew of.
These are not lies that in society we're told to look out for.
It'd be one like everyone's like,
does he have another family?
I don't even think about like your school.
Like who cares?
It's like lying about your blood type and let's not just his,
he lied about where most likely,
let's be honest,
most likely lied about his mom having cancer because you were dating a big heart
guy,
you know,
and he most likely lied.
Well,
he definitely lied about the skeleton bones part about England.
He lied about his house twice.
He lied about,
you know,
he sounds like a guy who just lies at a d.
It means probably gotten laid doing that his whole life.
I don't think he's gotten late enough.
I think that's what it was.
I'm just thinking about it.
No,
because I don't think it's,
he's not like I totally got tricked.
I'm not above admitting that.
I'm also not above admitting that.
I think when you love someone,
you're judgment is clouded and I didn't,
I didn't know the scope of what that could be.
I didn't in a billion years I wouldn't have thought that that was really,
I thought it was a joke that like,
oh,
we can't find his yell diploma,
whatever,
but you almost don't want it to be true.
There's the thing that's going to happen in our lifetimes,
I believe were lying is going to be a thing of the past.
I really do believe that we can't anymore.
I think technology is moving us along that trail where there's gonna come a
point in time where we're going to have a connection with each other.
That's not as simple as just talking.
I think they're on the way.
Did you see that new Google thing that they came up with?
Their Google is working on a contact lens right now that monitors your glucose
levels for diabetics and does all kinds of weird shit like the same along the
same lines of Google glass,
but far more complex and,
and,
and analyzes your body when we're dealing with these kind of technological human
interfaces is symbiotic relationship with people and electronics.
We're event,
it's eventually gonna make its way to communication and then I think that just
the,
the lines of communication and it's one of the things that they've been
speculating on that we're going to be able to read each other's minds.
Essentially.
We're going to be able to exchange thought through Wifi there.
There's,
I think I saw something recently about that like telekinesis,
but like mind control and be able to move things just because,
but if that contact lens can manage your glucose levels,
that means it can monitor other levels,
which means it could be a lie detector test.
Yes.
That's a walking truth serum in your motherfucking,
Huh?
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah,
and you're going to be able to see whether or not someone has it on or off.
Oh my God.
You have your lie detector blocked,
like you'll be able to see like blocks almost like Facebook set to private.
Yes.
Yeah.
If they have is her Twitter back,
they have a big lock on their Twitter Twitter page.
That's also shit by the way,
like that's my other thing.
When people rights,
I tweet about this the other day.
People write something Shitty to you,
but then they have like a locked or private profile.
You don't get to erase that person mean like you don't get to have an opinion.
Oh,
I blocked them anyway.
I blocked everyone who says anything even remotely Shitty,
if that's how you're trying to respond,
get me to respond.
Or are you just trolling or whatever you're trying to do is one thing.
They've,
you have a legitimate criticism.
I appreciate legitimate criticisms cause you know,
you,
even if I don't agree with their assessment,
I think that objectively it's,
it's,
it's a very valuable asset,
especially if they're intelligent to hear and intelligent person's take on you,
even if it's negative and intelligent fan who wants to,
they just want to interact.
Yes.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I actually once in a while depend on people.
I,
I'm a huge grammar stickler.
So when people write back and I'll make a mistake,
I'll write the wrong thing and they'll correct it.
I'll go back and I'll erase that tweet and repost it.
Me Too.
Yeah.
It doesn't bother me one bit and I'll say thanks.
Thanks for the heads up.
Like I,
a lot of times on my phone to my eyes are starting to go to shit too.
I'm 46 now and um,
I,
I'll wear reading glasses if I'm reading a book now over the last like year,
this is the new thing.
But if I'm looking at Twitter,
if uh,
like I'm on a plane or something like that,
if I'm looking at it on my phone,
it started like,
I can read this like loud and clear.
No problem whatsoever.
But weird little small things are starting to get blurry.
They're starting to get blurry in some weird way.
So I'll occasionally fuck up a word,
not realize it until I post it.
And I'm like,
God dammit the worst.
Especially when you'd like or on Instagram is the worst because you can edit it.
We deleted,
I did it the other day.
I wrote silly butch,
but I meant silly bitch.
But my phone corrected it to silly butch.
Ah,
autocorrect,
why can't we turn that off shit and shot too.
She said Shit a thousand times.
Why You keep riding shot?
You know what I mean?
Shit,
you fuck mine won't let me write the word food.
It always changes it too good.
And I'm like,
these are both legitimate words that are used often and it's just got this
thing.
It's a living,
breathing thing.
Yeah.
And you're connected to it.
I'm upset.
I'm so she'd,
I'm playing with it the entire time.
We're on the,
no,
I have not had it off.
Yeah,
I see what you're doing.
If anybody,
but I can't read this far away by tweets.
You,
you can't read these in the show.
I can't read from this far away.
Are Your eyes going?
They were gone.
I had gone and I patch when I was a little,
you had to wear an eye patch and I have a one week I and it knows you're a
pirate.
Ooh.
Everything I could read.
If I do that,
I can read it.
Barely.
Um,
I want,
I told you before the show that I wanted to talk to you about this video that I
saw because traditional male and female roles and the arguments,
the traditional male female arguments are so fucking stupid to me.
I get so upset when people get in.
These men do this and women want this.
Women why Comedy Act No.
Like this comedy.
But then there's these,
these generally's generalizations that one of the things that I hate about talk
shows or about,
uh,
you know,
one of those CNN things where they have people debate and I split screen the
split screen debates or God,
they're fucking five minutes or whatever they are.
You're not going to get to the heart of any matter.
And most of the time there's a little bit of correctness on both sides.
Both sides have points,
both sides of,
and everyone's just trying to win.
And this,
this video that I sent that Jamie,
you got that video right?
This videos?
Yup.
Perfect example of this.
The weirdness.
You could see it up here and you'll hear it.
[inaudible] headphones.
The perfect example of the fucking weirdness that exists in,
in human beings when it comes to male,
female relationships are women unhappier because of money.
And now this is the debate that these,
uh,
these people were having
no study out today that says women become on happy as they get older.
Well,
the flip side,
men get happier as life goes on.
Pause it for a second.
Hold on.
First of all,
I fucking hate studies.
Those kinds of stuff.
Study was from,
first of all,
I don't mind clinical studies on drugs and chemicals and you know,
those things make sense,
but study fine said women are sadder and men are happier.
Survey I conducted on the toilet this morning,
I find those things to be bullshit ways to start conversations about things and
provoke arguments that are designed to get ratings on fucking shitty talk show.
I was like,
sure.
I mean that's what a lot of it is.
We are the word study and we're like,
Ooh,
scientifically legitimate.
Well,
not only that,
who they talked to,
did they talk to you?
Eliza swessinger did not help to me.
He didn't talk to me either.
They didn't talk to anybody.
I know I fucking hate surveys because I think that surveys do not give you an
accurate assessment of what most people want or the belief they give you an
assessment of people dumb enough to answer surveys who were at like an outdoor
mall.
Yeah,
like a dollar the answer yet.
And they're idiots.
But for the most part you're dealing with dummies.
Okay.
Couple of economists by the way.
They say it happens when we eat.
Christmas wig looks great and all of the major factors.
I'm coming down all about money now.
What's that all about?
We're going to the faded mark.
Rudolph is a no nonsense man and Tracy burns are Fox business reporter joins me
to tell us what's really going on.
Tracy.
This is true.
Come on.
All right.
First of all,
they know you've missed me,
mark.
First of all,
this study was conducted by mostly men and when men conduct anything,
they talk about their finances because men judge themselves by this,
the size of their wallet.
Toys,
dare I say
no,
hold on.
Yeah.
How crazy is that when men do this,
men do that.
Not all men do that,
dummy.
Knowing that,
do you have to mean,
look,
if we,
if we harped on specifics,
we would never get any worse.
So it's not an incorrect generalization.
I do think men do.
I mean most see fortune 500 company Ceos are men and I do think that's a huge
thing for men.
That is how it it.
He because we can't fight with swords and shields anymore.
Like that is a way that men judge each other.
They certainly do.
And women do as well.
And that's this guy's point.
Some women do some.
Um,
but the idea that this study was definitely done by men and it's judge judging
men.
The women are unhappy because they get older.
It's like,
but I think you're judging.
Okay.
Sorry,
go ahead.
No,
let's let it play out.
I just let it play out because it's,
it's,
it's fascinating
and it's makes you happy.
If they were to ask other questions in this study about spirituality,
about the other aspects of our lives that women would have taken over.
I mean,
first of all,
a woman has her sexual prime at 35 things get much better for us.
Hey,
I made 35 this is good.
Alright.
Alright,
go nuts cause I know you're going to go nuts.
Good one.
Yeah.
Well first of all,
you're presuming that the unhappiness and women begins in middle age.
I'd say it starts when she's a little girl.
When she stopped that happiness derives from shoes,
jewelry,
Boob,
jobs,
and pedal.
Okay,
stop right there.
Okay.
He's a fucking idiot too.
That's an idiotic thing to say that they're unhappy from the time they're a
little girl.
No,
no.
Some of them are happy as fuck.
You know,
he's weird generalizations to try to prove your point or to make like your
gender,
the correct one.
Like it's men versus women.
All right.
Versus all women.
It's so dumb.
Okay.
First it drives me crazy.
First of all,
I disagree with you.
I do think we need generalizations.
We couldn't have comedy without generalizations.
Well,
we have some generalizations for the sake of comedy,
but it comes up.
That guy's awful and that woman is off.
Like those people are horrible people.
So it's not a horrible yeah,
Bay,
but they're horrible people.
Uh,
he is not wrong and it is,
I mean,
he's not wrong.
It does start younger.
I do think girls are conditioned to be less happy with themselves and to compete
with each other in an unhealthy way from a very young age.
But I don't think women are unhappy.
But I do think that there are,
there are more,
there's more variables that women have to deal with in terms of like body
issues,
competition,
that is,
that originates from women.
Less about men.
Like we think we're always competing with men.
We're really competing
with other women.
So I don't think he's wrong and saying that,
but he's saying there,
yeah,
he's definitely awful.
But they're saying that they're unhappy.
He's awful in these,
well,
it's like these are the,
also these are such inflammatory,
I mean,
I don't want to judge any of these people because it's not a real conversation
that it's awful in these inflammatory bursts of information.
It's like at a certain point in time,
you know,
you have to stop doing these fucking five minute conversations translates to the
carpet warehouse business.
We're here on Fox business trying to get to the heart of the matter.
Why girls are unhappy.
Oh,
I mean it's all garbage.
I mean,
most of this,
all of this is just to to pay for advertising.
Yeah.
Like a buzzfeed,
like top 10 top 10 brick colors.
You should see.
And the reason why Jennifer Aniston will never be happy.
Like what?
Press press play there,
Jamie.
Interesting.
Oh,
come on,
I'll Alexis.
And then you have boys who are taught that they're supposed to make girls happy.
I was on the radio two weeks ago in Greensboro,
North Carolina,
and the host related a story.
He overheard his son and daughter talking.
So brother goes to sister and says,
how come you always have money?
And I don't.
And she says,
that's simple.
I have a boyfriend and you have a girlfriend.
The fact of the matter is,
boy,
your pocket,
they're supposed to make women happy.
I mean the people that watch Fox,
no,
not living in the dark ages.
This is reality.
And if either of you women has ever dated women,
you would know what I'm talking about.
But you pretend that you don't know what I'm about.
What?
What's happening in middle age,
what's happening?
What's happening in middle age here is that women who bring 70% of divorces are
divorcing the men that they never wanted the marriage to begin with.
And so now that's what's making the men happy.
That's the green because we control the household spending,
don't we?
Cause we were working more than ever.
All right,
let's get back to the surveys.
Right?
Because basically what they're saying is that we are happy here in our early
adult life and that women are more likely than men to fulfill their aspirations
earlier related to material goods and family.
That is true when you say true because you can't have a baby when you're 60 men
longer to figure out what they want to do in life.
Well,
I just think this whole notion of basing your happiness on material goods,
it's part of the problem.
Hence part of the reason that this thing was run by men in the first place.
You know what I'm arguing,
she's right.
In some ways,
basing
your happiness on material possessions is pretty foolhardy,
but the whole men thing,
that's why it's run by men like no,
it's run by people that think in a silly way.
You know this,
this men versus women argument,
it's,
I,
I fucking hate those kinds of generalizations because you're railing against the
way that this debate was set up versus actual content.
While I'm reeling against these fucking squatters chickens squawking NHL that
she had a terrible host.
Terrible.
The fact that I can't get a show,
but this,
somebody gave this meat puppet.
It's not that you can't get a show Eliza slessinger.
You need a God.
Damn.
That's what you need.
Why don't you do a podcast a lot the size you are.
You're a powerful woman.
Brought that up the other day to who?
My manager to fucking manager.
Just do it.
Why don't you just do it?
You could do it here.
I'll let you use my studio.
Can I take the hideaway?
You could get the throw the thing in the garbage.
Well he's my friend gave it to me so you can't throw it away.
You can put it away.
I would like to,
it doesn't have to look at it.
All right,
so your issue is with the way that this,
I mean those people are,
you are getting,
you said to me earlier like why give something like bad?
Your energy.
These people are horrible and it's on Fox.
So I don't know what we were expecting.
Well,
we were expecting bad things,
but uh,
in analyzing bad things you can break down what's so goofy about them.
And I think that there are some clarity comes out of that.
So it's a let this guy like,
oh yeah,
it gets even goofier.
Okay.
This is why I wanted to bring it up to you.
I felt like your personality is a uniquely qualified to show the other side of
it.
Yeah.
And all they would,
I mean ask any woman if she went to her car over her children and so you take
the kids any day.
Whereas I would question a lot of men out there.
All right.
That's fine.
Fucking,
that's horrible.
That's such a dumb thing to say.
She had a chance to make a salient point and she said something's really
horrible.
Any guy who would choose his car over his kids should just vanish from the
planet.
Probably not as instantly.
Instantly vanished from the planet.
Yeah.
Mark,
let me tell you,
it is because we are stronger and we are happier at the end of the day than most
men.
And that is factual and you know,
it's a heart thing.
I just wanted to die sooner
on the table if you want to play this game,
right?
Yeah.
Women go around comparing their engagement rings to show off.
Who got the most careful Tommy?
That women don't compete,
that Joe kind of stuff.
Mari,
knock it out.
Word compete on houses,
divorce,
settlements,
carrots,
country clubs.
Women compete on money all the time.
Give me a break
your life buddy.
How's that for a second?
Just pretend the date.
Don't he's so disingenuine I agree.
But I also first there again,
I have to read her.
Write how horrible that Paula Abdul looking one on the bottom is a nightmare.
She is disingenuous.
I 100%.
He's not wrong.
Uh,
he threw a punch so she threw one back.
Women do compete,
but so do men.
I think women do it,
uh,
on not a nit.
Pick your level,
but I don't think if you look at the reasons that I'd have to think about it for
the,
the reasons we're doing this,
I don't think that they come from a horrible place.
And I think men play into it.
You're buying her that diamond ring because you want to show how big your bank
account is and that you're powerful and that she's worth,
I mean,
everybody's playing a part in this.
Nobody's innocent hundred percent.
And you're also dating.
You made the choice to date that this is my issue.
He made the choice to date that
horrible woman who thinks the biggest diamond in the world is a big deal.
So what does that say about your decision making skills?
But when you first start dating someone,
oftentimes you don't know that they're going to be a horrible person,
but they didn't go to Yale.
I fucking get that.
Exactly.
Uh,
no,
you know,
yeah.
You know,
when that girl is horrible,
I see a lot of what you do,
but sometimes you're deep in it and you're trying to like work it out anyway.
Like I know that I,
I,
this is the pot calling kettle black because I can't talk about it cause I just
told you that horrible story that not what you made an awesome story.
I awesome.
Sorry.
I think a lot of men,
um,
I think different parts,
men and women in different kinds of simulation and that's just the truth.
Not all men need to be challenged by like a smart girl or if or an intelligent
woman or something like that.
A lot of men are okay with like a dumb hot girl that wants to like cook his
meals and just kind of be there.
A lot of men are okay with that.
George Harrison once said that all I need from a woman is to be attracted to
her.
Everything else I can get from a man.
I do think a lot of men,
I don't even care if that's wrong or right,
everyone is allowed to feel that way.
And I think men on the whole are on the whole are more program that way and
women need a lot of external stimuli.
And this also plays into the bedroom as well.
So you're not,
women need to be stimulated by a man more by his mind,
respecting his mind,
respecting his,
uh,
his English.
You're a gold digger,
in which case you're awful and you deserve nothing.
But I mean for me,
like if you're stupid,
even if you're the hottest guy ever,
like I can't write.
I can't.
Could you like make out with them and take your top off or am I got 100 even?
I've been out with really hot guys and I'm like,
I have to leave right now.
Right,
right,
right.
Cause you it's offensive.
Yeah.
Well I,
yeah,
I can totally get that.
Okay.
Keep going with that.
The stature of a lot of men is measured in the car.
They drive the golf country club they belong to and very much the place they
live in.
You have to admit that.
Yeah.
And whether or not their wives are staying at home and not working.
That's exactly what I said at the beginning,
that the way the men are taught that they have to make women happy.
But the fact of the matter is you can't make anybody happy.
You have to make yourself happy.
He's right.
Happiness is a byproduct of achievement.
So for women to say that they're unhappy,
it's their own fault.
Anybody who says he's unhappy,
it's his own fault.
Everybody has to make himself or herself happy.
Bloody headed.
Yeah.
I mean,
how are you from?
Where are you from?
She says bloody like girls that they have to grow up to be reliant on a man as
you can.
Well,
you can say that.
My son pray for your the same one.
Nope.
Same One.
Who bragged that she's so strong and so tough and doesn't need a man's money?
Yeah,
you're taking alimony.
Oh,
mark.
he's wrong.
Sorry.
Hold on.
He's wrong.
How's he wrong?
Here's how he's wrong because I've thought about this for you.
Raise these children together.
I mean,
you have these children together.
She gave up.
People aren't gonna like this,
but is the truth.
A woman has a finite amount of time to have a baby.
Okay.
And a finite amount of time to really be valuable in the workplace.
As unfortunate as it is,
that's the way it is.
Your youth is a commodity,
right?
When you enter into a contract of marriage with someone,
you're giving up a big part of yourself to either support that man and what he's
doing to have these children to raise these children.
So part of that alimony is,
and this is just the way it is,
is sort of compensation for all those years you invested in that he is still
going to be at 50 he can still be just as valuable as he wasn't 25 for a woman.
It just isn't that way yet.
He should have to pay for the children as much as she does.
She's the one raising them.
So his financial contribution is the compensation for not physically being
there.
She's the one taking them to doctor's appointments.
She's the one staying up with them when they're sick.
I,
my mom was a single mom who,
I don't know what happened with her Alamo situation,
but I don't think that that's wrong.
You can be a strong woman,
but he doesn't get to just dip out because they had kids and they got a divorce.
I completely agree with you as far as supporting the person who's taking care of
your children,
that you absolutely have to make a,
a financial contribution to that.
And I also think that alimony is a,
is a big part of that.
Not just child support but compensating the woman for the,
the actual time that she has that you,
if you're not going to give the time,
if you're not going to be there,
you will.
You absolutely should give them money.
And My,
my issue with alimony really is with people who don't have children,
women who don't have children.
I have a buddy who was married to a woman for um,
when you're married for a certain amount of years.
I don't know what the number is,
but he passed over that number.
It doesn't matter what your,
you know,
your status is.
It doesn't matter what it is.
You have to,
unless you have a prenuptial,
you have to take care of her for the rest of her natural life.
It's like 12
that's ridiculous.
But to my point,
it's one thing,
I guess if you get married at 50 and you read for five years and that's
different,
but okay,
let's,
let's look at this scenario.
Well I think he was married at 2020 I'm 22 or something like that and they
divorced when she was like 35 or something like that.
So she's still young enough to get a man,
but he has to take care of her for the rest of her life.
And she's living in his old house.
He this fucking jam and house and the Pacific Palisades overlooking the ocean.
W if she lives with a man,
she's no longer eligible so she can't get married.
So she has a boyfriend,
but she will not marry the boyfriend because my friend is wealthy and he has to
pay her a large sum.
So they play this game where he has a lawyer,
go to the house and says,
you're living with a man.
She says,
no,
he's just staying the night and he doesn't live here.
And then the guy has to move out and they hire investigators to make sure that
this guy is not sleeping over all the time.
So the guy tries to sneak in through the fucking backyard to stay.
I mean,
it's incredible.
Um,
I,
that's terrible.
Yes.
Here's the other side of that.
And I'm not,
the older I get,
the more I'm able to see both sides versus being like,
oh,
it's about not taking advantage of med or being a strong woman.
Let's say you're 21 and you get married and the guy says,
and you want you kids,
and the guy says,
I
don't want kids.
Okay.
And you get divorced at 35,
let's say,
let's say older,
younger,
whatever.
You've pretty much given up the bulk of your child bearing years.
You will never have a family now and,
and you're divorced and you're pretty much left with nothing.
And the years that you could have dick,
let's just say dedicated to having a career or whatever.
Let's say you spent them supporting going through medical school.
Let's say you were there for him.
And a lot of guys do this and they leave their call.
A starter wife,
I don't know about being compensated for the rest of your life but there should
be some compensation there for the love and the pain and the support and
everything that you went through to support that man who you thought was going
to be the rock for the rest of your life.
Well that's a very specific scenario you're bringing up and that scenario isn't
covered by laws that are very generalized.
I do think,
oh there's generalities nipping in the bud.
Again in that specific scenario,
woman putting a got through medical school,
I absolutely agree with you.
She just supporting him just being his wife.
Maybe she gave up having kids for him,
like there's certain,
if you will.
In this particular scenario,
this woman actually couldn't have kids.
She had a medical situation and one of the reasons why they broke up was because
he wanted a family and she couldn't have kids for whatever reason.
I mean,
I don't know what else they fought about,
but it wasn't a good relationship in many ways.
So I bumped,
my friend is tortured by this.
Sure.
And she's a pariah.
And I do,
I think that for every woman that does that,
it sort of takes away the legitimacy of the argument that like women need to be
on their own and be strong.
And the alimony thing that he brought up is absolute bullshit.
But like this woman,
if you have a boyfriend and like you're pretty much stopping yourself from being
married and happy so you can have money.
You can live in an apartment.
You don't need to live in a mansion in the Palisades.
She's terrible friend is rich and she's making mad loot from him.
He pays her hundreds of thousands of dollars a year.
That's a horrible law.
Uh,
that's is terrible.
And he has to pay her for the rest of her life.
The rest of your life is ridiculous.
I can understand a couple of years to get you back on your feet.
Go get a job,
but someone he needs to get a,
I don't know.
I don't know what he's going to do.
Well,
I can understand a couple of years to get you on your feet as well because if
the guy's completely supporting you and then all of a sudden he pulls the net
out from I do.
And you're like,
Holy Shit,
how do I feed myself?
I need to get a fucking job.
But you know,
if you're a grown human being,
you probably have some sort of a occupational skill.
That's the other thing.
That's the argument for don't have you.
And she said this,
you raise,
you should raise your children to be,
to self support and not rely on it.
It's not about,
I don't need a man.
It's,
I like taking care of myself.
I would love a guy to take care of me,
but I'd also like to contribute.
I want to be married.
Of course,
it'd be great if you paid for vacation,
but I can also pay the mortgage on the house.
Like it should be.
Uh,
it should be a bipartisan effort.
And if the person doesn't need you,
it's nice if you don't need each other and find that more attractive.
I think,
I think weak men find it attractive when a girl has to depend on them for
everything.
And I think any quality man respects a woman that can buy her own things and
doesn't want anything from them.
Well,
especially if a guy's been through a scenario like that,
like my friends scenario where you're dealing with a woman,
it's just sponging off you for the rest of your days.
I mean,
he's never going to have sex with her again.
They're never hugging and don't go on vacations together.
There's no loving kisses and he's sending hundreds of thousands of dollars every
year her way.
You gotta be honest.
I'm sorry.
I think you could have spotted that she was a little horrible from the get go.
People don't usually turn into that.
You're do.
This is where I disagree because it's not a moral compass issue.
It's an issue of convenience for her.
Why should she go out and get more?
Well,
it's not morals.
It's like if someone gives you a lottery ticket and says,
Hey,
you know,
you,
you won the winning lottery.
Um,
but if you get this lottery ticket,
you really would never going to have to work again.
You're probably not going to pursue your career,
but hey,
you're going to have millions of dollars.
Now.
Most people are going to take those millions of dollars and those millions of
dollars most likely are going to fuck up your motivation.
They're gonna,
they're gonna make you look at money and a completely different way.
It's a moral thing because if I said,
here's a lottery ticket and you're going $1 million,
but it's going to seriously,
uh,
encumber an inconvenience,
somebody else who doesn't deserve it necessarily rich,
he's rich,
why should he care?
I mean,
if he makes,
let's,
let's give them a number,
say $10 million a year.
If he makes $10 million a year,
why should he care if he has to send 500 grand her way every year?
Okay,
so here's this then.
And here's why.
I think it's a moral thing.
There's also like an,
uh,
there's also the idea that like I find it disgusting to have to rely on someone
that you don't have any use for.
A perfect example is the Yale thing.
The day I met him,
he would say,
this is where it has,
it all ties in.
He would say,
I have a billion miles on whatever airline.
And he was like,
give me your itinerary and I will upgrade you every time you fly.
And it's,
it's easy.
I've got all these free upgrades,
you may as well use them.
So I was like,
okay.
So when we started dating,
I would like to use the upgrades and even after we broke up,
he was like,
I'd still like to keep giving you upgrades.
I couldn't keep taking them.
I think I took like one more upgrade,
like while we were breaking up.
Right.
But I,
in that email I was like,
this is my resignation from the upgrade program can go fuck yourself.
It's not worth it to me to fly first class to be tied to you in any way,
shape or form.
And this woman is in a cosmic way.
Keeping yourself tethered to this man and as a man dating her,
would you be comfortable like living in some other dude's house with some other
Dude's money?
Like that's the whole thing is awful.
And so I do think it's a moral issue.
Um,
I see your point.
And um,
I would not,
but some men would broke.
Man would,
would.
Um,
you know,
I know a guy who's an actor who's got this girl who takes care of them
completely.
She works all day and he just goes to auditions and to disastrous relationship.
And I've watched it so like,
it's horrific to watch.
Cause like,
man,
if he ever does make it,
most likely he's going to bail for sure.
The whole thing is,
it's also,
there's a weird resentment that comes from guy who's depending on a woman to
take care of them.
And depending on a woman who's also depending on another man,
it's this weird fucking entangles behavior.
And you see it in la all the time.
But I think in her eyes it's like,
Hey,
this guy can afford it.
Fuck him.
I gave him 12
years of my life and he fucking left me because,
oh,
because then the kids think,
well,
I don't know to quite honestly,
he doesn't really,
I know they,
they,
they weren't getting along great.
It wasn't as simple as like the,
she was the love of his life,
but she couldn't have kids.
You know,
I dropped,
you know,
no,
it wasn't that.
It was,
there was a lot of other issues too,
but they were together long enough and they were married young.
So there was that thing where like,
hey,
we're going to be together forever.
We don't need a prenuptial.
Right.
And now he,
if any of his friends or even thinking about marriage,
he grabs him by the collar and says,
get up fucking prenuptial.
And he tells him the whole story
and he's an idiot.
Why?
Because he didn't have a prenup and she was awful from the young,
well,
I promise you she was,
I promise you she was.
I can tell you,
I promise I could look at a woman and tell you if she's horrible.
Let's,
let's say this.
Let's say you're both young and the guy is like really ambitious and the woman
is an artist and you know she doesn't make any money doing what she does,
but he supports that she does that.
Maybe she's a photographer,
let's say she's one of those artists things where it's like really fucking hard
to make money.
Well,
I mean maybe she's in new and maybe he doesn't care,
but then one day along the line,
12 years later he starts carrying,
he's like,
look,
it's over.
And now she has spent these 12 years being taken care of and has never even
considered being able to make a living on her own.
She's awful.
You don't give up your dream first of all.
And that goes back to what we were talking about here you are,
are you a bad photographer?
And the guy,
men typically don't care if the girls bad.
I know plenty of men that like date female comics and they're comics too and the
girl is horrible.
That's so common and the guys are over.
I don't care.
And I'm like,
I could never date a comic that told horrible Dick Jokes for a living
that they take them on the road with them and they have the girl.
Let's keep it on the DL.
But yeah,
I mean there's for every Tom Segura and Christina,
Christina Pezeshki where they're both hilarious.
Yes.
There's these scenarios where one of them,
aw shit.
Absolutely.
They are the rare occasion,
I think.
Fine,
you're a photographer.
Let's say a good,
let's say you're bad.
What on this earth things you have the right to stop trying to evolve as a
person just because you're married.
We'll meet it end.
Maybe he put it out there,
maybe.
He said,
look,
I love you.
You don't ever have to work again.
What are you doing though?
You don't have kids.
So what are you doing?
Lunching each taking care of a little dog named blanche.
I still work in blanch ward.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
maybe she just does that.
And you know,
if you meet a woman here,
I'm gonna Give you how much fucking yogurt can you do every day?
Do a little yoga every day and then you recover and get a massage.
Manny petty,
I would feel like such a beautiful book is there.
A girl does not read and the secret doesn't count.
Let's see.
Can Either do magazine US weekly.
It doesn't count for reading.
I'm a reader.
I read a lot of,
uh,
cows,
his hamster cage lining,
hamster cage.
I take care of my hamsters gentleman.
If you meet a girl and she's willing to take that and just be like,
I'll just,
and,
and she's not an active role in the relationship,
but she's not taking care of you and you're just,
and she's just pretty and that's it.
Okay.
But isn't there more to life than just making money?
And if you,
you're in a relationship with someone and you really truly feel like they're
going to be together forever,
we shouldn't that person just to be able to there.
There's enough money between the two of you.
Were both of your living very comfortably.
Shouldn't you be able to do whatever you want?
Course?
Yeah,
sure.
Don't come.
Don't be upset when it comes back to bite you in the bud that you don't have a
career 15 years later.
Right.
And he left you.
I also,
I mean I guess I just want to know what she does during the day.
Like I,
I can kill a day looking at Facebook,
right?
But then the next day I'll be
busy.
Like what are you doing?
Well maybe she kills days looking at Facebook and the next day she's not busy.
She just keeps looking at Facebook.
She's does what you do.
But always look,
I can't judge if somebody has a pea brain,
but I don't.
These are awful people.
And you're terrible people.
Well,
one one's terrible,
my friends,
not terrible friends.
A little terrible.
Why is he terrible?
Fred's little terrible.
Cause he married her and she was,
oh come on.
I don't know about that.
When you were in your 20s you don't fucking know shit.
I mean you couldn't figure out a guy was full of shit and you're 30 and smart.
I figured it out though.
You figured it out eventually after a lot of cross examination and investigative
work involving your mother as well
theirself.
And second of all,
she always involves herself.
Second of all,
what is a mental disorder?
And one's a full on personality disorder.
The fact that he's a psychopath and he's probably skilled at covering out these,
it's like a path.
It's an,
I'm sorry that I don't work on criminal minds.
She,
I can tell you from her nail length and what kind of jeans she wears and how
about her fake Tan is,
I can tell you what a fucking nightmare this woman is from the get go.
So I think one,
these are outward clues versus like subversive clues.
Hmm.
What's that?
Kombucha.
Oh,
okay.
So I'm a woman who is into nice clothes and nice nails.
I didn't say that.
No,
I didn't say he's into it.
And I can tell by the type the type,
but what is the type that a guy should look out for?
If you're a,
you're going to give a seminar how guys should avoid nightmare horrible women in
their life,
which should they avoid
you.
Okay.
First of all,
it's a case by case basis.
There's plenty of different horrible things.
Of course,
if she's got big old French tip nails,
she's a little bit of white trash.
Okay.
Friendship nails are bad.
Like long press on French tip nails would,
if they're real nails,
they're French.
French tip is,
to me it's just such a trashy book,
but that's fine.
Okay.
Um,
what about like dark red,
like Spanish girl with red lipstick and dark red nails?
It depends on the girl.
It's a whole package because you could have trashy elements like I'm wearing cut
off jeans right now in a see through tank top.
That's what I'm talking about.
Ready to judge you.
But the rest of me is not Polish.
It's not like the rest I've got like messy hair and one foot painted.
Is that okay?
It's okay because I'm like not trying.
Okay.
I think it's just,
there's just certain looks that women have and I don't want to say,
oh,
it's this hairdo.
It's that there's a hole and you know what I'm talking about.
It's a whole myriad of elements that come together.
Does she?
And there's nothing
wrong with having like enhancements.
Does she have fake lips and fake tits and hair extensions and clause Andy,
she weren't stripper heels.
Well then she's probably fucking horrible.
Like let's get serious lucite heels like indoors.
That's pretty rare though isn't it?
I mean I'm pretty extreme examples.
I don't even know what realm we're dealing with here.
Big Lip thing is,
that's a crazy one too.
Like they never really worked that out in so many girls jumped on that
bandwagon.
Excuse me.
Jumped on that bandwagon and they fucked up their face forever.
I think women in Hollywood make a decision.
They're like,
I would rather look super weird than look super old.
Cause when you like a lot of them you can't tell what they are,
how old they are.
They're so weird.
There's this woman that I see at my daughter's school and I drop my kid off in
the morning and she's,
it makes me sad because this lady,
she,
she looked like she was probably pretty when she was younger and she's not that
old.
She's probably in her late thirties maybe early forties but she has turned her
face into that a monster,
a monster,
and there's no going back.
It's rubber,
it doesn't move.
It's frozen.
It's filled in in weird ways where it looks like she's got up fucking tooth ache
or something like her face is swollen and she,
you know what the kicker is?
She might've gotten him for one thing,
had a weird reaction or whatever and like now it's like that and she might be a
super cool lady or something and that's just like,
like you're stuck with that.
Well you know what I think it is.
I think it's a dysmorphia.
Like the same thing where anorexics habit bodybuilders have it.
Women who have a boob implants a lot of times never think their boob implants
are big enough.
They want to keep going and going and going and getting bigger and bigger.
They get,
they get crazy,
they look at them and they're like not big enough.
Like they don't see what everyone else is seeing.
Also when you don't have big boobs from the get go,
you don't realize like how annoying they can be.
Right.
I'm just saying,
well you have natural big boobs.
Did they fuck with your back?
No,
because they're not like so big that it's like,
I mean those girls that have like back issues like those are like gigantic,
like black lady bras.
Yeah.
I dated a girl who had natural ones that were just enormous and she wound up
getting a reduction because there there's doers just crazy.
They were out of control.
They're like ease.
They were enormous.
There's this,
if we're going to get personal about it,
like especially like for like your lady time sometimes like your boobs get
bigger.
I'm putting on a shirt.
I'm just like,
even I get annoyed.
Like I'm saying,
I need to put these things away and like things just don't quite fit.
I try to put on a dress yesterday and I was like,
this is inappropriate and you're just trying to like make it fucking work.
But,
but there are also weapons of math manipulatives drop.
You pull those out and do just go holy.
But Jesus,
we were ill.
I mean like motorboating I mean like the look that they get like a cartoon look.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I don't notice it.
And I only say that because I think when you grow up a certain way,
like if you're tall,
like you don't notice that you're like,
you don't think about it and then you kind of,
you're used to be always be like when we go,
you were tall.
If you have big boobs,
if you,
since I'm 14 years old,
it's always been a thing.
So I don't,
it doesn't make me uncomfortable.
I even think about
it.
I don't even notice people looking and if they do,
it's very comfortable.
Well you do Sorta,
I mean that's why he said you make out with the guy and take off your shirt and
that's a nice treat for him.
Oh yeah.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like in general,
like I don't,
I'm very comfortable around a bra.
I don't care.
It's not something that you think about on a regular.
Right,
right.
I think about my boobs.
I bet you do.
I would if I had them like yours.
I touch him.
I'll tell you about them.
All girls do.
I'd be willing to whip them out at the drop of a hat to,
nope,
not fallen for that one.
I'm totally,
what are words?
You have another show you,
you're going somewhere else.
I'm just looking behind me.
This,
I thought you were making a lot more sense.
It's two 40 you have to bug you,
right?
I wasn't say one more thing.
Okay.
About that clip.
[inaudible] women need to learn.
It's very easy in an argument for like I was,
I'm conditioned to,
when I watched that side,
even though that guy was horrible to almost go against women like women when
they argue become very ugly women.
I think if they learn to be more composed and calmer,
it was women who were raising their voices.
They sounded like chickens.
They can't.
They block like blood chickens.
That guy was calm.
You notice blood chicken,
great.
That's a great name for a band.
Like the blood blood.
Chicken's good night ice house it up for pussy riot next month in prison.
They're out.
Oh,
they did great.
That guy,
you notice he didn't raise his voice.
He was,
even though he was a Douche,
like everything was very calm and the women were just like,
I'm proving that.
Then I'm strong and I'm this,
come on bloody hell.
What are you?
Oh Lord,
who are you dating and don't?
Yeah,
don't yell.
Well if just because you can,
if they,
if they kept it calm and they talked like this,
I would have so much more respect for women in debates.
Or You Watch Hillary Clinton,
she doesn't freak out and get high fee like that.
And those women were awful.
And I think if women just chill the fuck out and stop trying to prove to every
woman,
I'm so strong,
I'm independent,
I'm the all the real housewives.
That's all they do.
Stop trying to prove what you aren't and just fucking take a deep
well that's one of those things that also doesn't work.
Like saying I'm strong,
I'm independent.
No one believes that.
You can't just say it.
It's just like name dropping you,
you feel compelled to say because you have a weak character.
Yeah.
But if you really are strong and you really are independent,
you don't give a fuck with this person,
thinks about you so that you don't have to say it.
You know it's,
it's one of those things that people do because they're trying to paint a
picture of themselves that oftentimes doesn't match up with reality.
That's my whole thing with,
I mean,
my own example is,
and I'm targeting real housewives of that whole franchise,
is that should drive you crazy.
I can't watch it anymore.
I used to watch all of them.
I can't because here you have these women,
these middle aged women,
desperate to prove to each other how fertile they are,
how young they are.
I could have a baby at 52 fucking can't you?
Cryogenic Monster.
Oh my skin care line.
Oh My,
this,
oh,
that's funded with your husband's money.
Here's what happened.
At 18 you got knocked up and thought you would have a go at like being a model.
So you moved to Hollywood or something.
Ended up getting married to some guy who probably fucking beat you and then at
when your kids were all raised,
you put your hand out of the sand and you were like,
okay,
now I'm going to try to be a human.
That's what all those women are.
Why don't you start out being a quality person?
Let life get in the way,
but deal with it.
Not like a garbage person and I won't hate you so much.
I drew boobs.
Well said.
Eliza slessinger.
You drew boobs there on that paper?
Yeah.
Well said.
Listen,
Eliza,
we got to do this more often.
This was fun.
It was real fun.
It,
it lived up to the height between us.
Like we had some hype going on.
I tracked you down in the airport.
Well,
we ran into each other.
I didn't track it down and then I had the worst flight ever and you didn't help
me at all.
We remember that guy like wouldn't stop talking.
The guy was sitting next to me.
Oh yeah.
You don't remember.
I do remember now.
I remember and I didn't realize he was drunk until like I need to pick up social
cues better,
but I didn't realize he was like wasted until like 20 minutes in and he like
kept talking.
I was brutal.
And you got to fake being asleep.
I fake being asleep for the whole flight to Miami Guy was one of those
California dorks.
There's a very specific type of California dude.
They're just like,
he was an idiot.
It made me,
it helped me to create,
I just tweeted after this something like if you played baseball in college are
probably horrible now.
Within five minutes he let me know that he used to play baseball.
Well that guy would have let you know anything about him.
He was a moron.
Every time I got up he would strike up the most inane conversations.
Like I was scared.
I was in the window and he was in the aisle on the other side.
Yeah.
So I would,
I would get up and as I was passing my friend to get towards your io,
he would start yapping at me all the way to the bathroom who had Yap.
All the way back.
He got up to meet me at the bathroom and I got out of the bathroom.
He's waiting for me there and it was like
done in there,
man.
I'm going in now,
Hey,
where are you going after he'd gone to Miami?
What's going on in Miami,
man,
you partied it up?
Miami.
Baru.
I used to party in Miami.
No,
partied up in Orange County.
He
was horrible.
Yeah,
he's a dumb ass.
Definitely dead now,
but he's not.
He will live forever and he will live forever in our imagination.
Eliza,
you the shit.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] Shlesinger there's clothes.
There you go.
Sleshinger Eliza,
you're awesome.
Thanks,
Jeremy.
Thanks.
Ah,
how do people find you besides Twitter?
What's your website?
It's [inaudible] dot com
I'm going to be in Seattle this weekend at the parlor.
Oh,
that's an awesome club.
My favorite club.
It's a great club parlor,
live.
It's got a pool hall connected to it that places the shit.
It's really good.
It's fantastic.
That's about as good a place as you can get in a alijah.com for more tour dates.
Please start a podcast.
You'll fucking podcast.
Is it go live is when you go to your website,
does it automatically start playing comedy?
That's my hour special.
Check out my hour special on Netflix.
It's called war paint.
Check it out,
bitches.
All right,
Eliza,
you're awesome.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Also to our sponsors.
Thank you to squarespace.com go to squarespace.com use the code word Joe
[inaudible],
Cheryl,
Cheryl Schroer money.
Thanks also to stamps.com go to stamps.com click on the microphone in the upper
right hand corner and the Code Word J
r e n get your freak on for $110 special offer,
including $55 worth of free postage and a free digital scale@stamps.com thanks.
Also to [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.N n.
I.
T.
You use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off all supplements.
Thank you so,
so much.
And I will be back in about 20 minutes with another podcast and this one is
going to be really fucking interesting.
I got a podcast coming up,
um,
with,
uh,
a guy who is a former world champion kickboxer,
a former motorcycle rider who was involved in the cleanup of the tsunami in,
uh,
in Thailand.
And it's going to be some really intense shit.
And Liam,
the guy who hooked this up is a,
a guy from a mixed martial arts.com,
a website that I frequent on a regular basis.
And He,
uh,
he,
he reached out to me and his brother is a Dylan and Dylan is going to be here.
So,
uh,
Dylan and Liam Resnick cough from Australia all the way to America.
We're going to have a fascinating podcast.
We're going to talk about martial arts.
We're going to talk about the Thailand tsunami.
We're going to talk about a lot of crazy shit and we'll see you in about 20,
25 minutes.
All right.
Much love lives as lessons.
Your go to eliza.com.
I love you kid.